at the end of time
[Music]
13. o'clock
how about now how about now go ahead and
give us a thumbs up you can hear the
sound yeah okay
sorry about that Jenny was saying she's
been spending uh several days I think
here
Mega said I think you're muted but I
think yeah I just I just turned it back
on yeah okay there it is yeah it was uh
the device turned itself because I it um
I had to update some stuff on the
computer like at seven o'clock and I
guess it turned the microphone off for
some reason if you guys haven't noticed
I cut Jenny's Hair
yeah I'll give her a goth haircut back
look it's all the way around it it's all
the way around yeah yeah turn your head
there you go see well yeah it was like
that before it's like that before I mean
I feel like we've done we've done the
show since it's been like that right
yeah
I just let it all grow out but then
summer's coming yeah I missed that
haircut
you were the one that told me to grow it
all out in the first place yeah that
looked good too but I started to miss
that haircut
and man I have so much hair yeah he's
cutting off last night that was just big
[__] pie yeah and I still have a
bunch left yeah it's kind of like sheer
and wool off of [__] I am telling you
this her hair is like she's got perfect
hair this shit's [__] dense
you can't believe there's that much hair
in a square inch yeah I can't it's like
down
it's a little I I imagine her head is
just burn it up it is yeah well like I
said plus every single day if like I
brush it and then there's hair all over
the floor and it's like you know what I
mean yeah
Trey said I can't pull that look off
anymore my hair is so gray I dye it but
it does not look right when I do it ever
thought of chopping it all off and doing
a pixie cut um I did do one like that
before and it's like I kind of like it
for a while but then what's that it's
just kind of like a real short oh okay I
mean yeah I've done it like that
I've done it like that before I thought
he was talking about a Chelsea I don't
know no that's like something different
like yeah yeah
but uh but yeah so like I said sorry
about the sound not being on y'all miss
my in the name of Jesus yeah I started
out with which yeah every time every
time I hear that I was just gonna say
every time I see every time I see one of
those evangelists I just hear the Front
242 song Something Something To Paradise
what was the name of that welcome repair
Welcome To Paradise yeah yeah
well she used a lot of I think that used
some of Jimmy Swaggart in there too like
among others that's who's one of the
ones we're going to talk about well the
thing about it is that when I decided to
do televangelist scandals I was like
this is going to be hard to like narrow
it down because it's like pretty much
every prominent one has at least one
yeah you know what I mean and most of
them I don't know if I want to say most
of them are sex scandals but a lot of
them are sex scandals
um they usually the ones that kind of
preach Prosperity Gospel which most of
the ones that we're talking about
tonight what's that's kind of the thing
that they did they usually end up
getting in trouble too for generally for
fraud and like misappropriating funds
and stuff like that like on top of other
like sexual scandals and things of that
but the song she's talking about is from
a band called front 242. and it's called
Welcome To Paradise that's the best
televangelism song of all times that's
even better than the Depeche Mode
Personal Jesus if you ask me I mean
that's a good song too but Welcome To
Paradise is just catchier and it's got
it's got sound bites from I think it's
Jimmy fall Jimmy Swagger didn't it some
of it's Jimmy Swaggart I think it's like
some different ones I can't remember
like who all you've just distorted his
voice is going in the name of Jesus
Hallelujah don't tell the devil
it kind of sounds like very early kmfdm
came fdm was copied a lot of Front 242
really well it's in the same genre that
song came like Welcome To Paradise I
think came out in 1988. because I kind
of feel like that yeah it is old well
and they still play it like at the clubs
and stuff yeah everybody's still dancing
and everybody's still dancing to it but
um yeah that's the thing well because I
kind of feel like the 80s were sort of
like the Heyday but it surprised me
doing some research into this [__] like
obviously I kind of feel like it's not
as prevalent as it once was but a lot of
this [__] is still going on the 700 Club
is still on yeah Jimmy Swaggart is still
alive Jim Baker is still alive yeah like
and there's they still have shows even
though they were supposedly disgraced
like all the [__] that they did they
still have money and they're still they
still have shows the thing about this do
we have anything that we have to talk
about before we you do we have any shout
outs or anything no okay I don't think
so think about this I remember in the
Heyday when all this [__] was going on
I was going to high school in Brazil in
an International High School and you had
a lot of Europeans there European uh
kids in the school we were all getting
IB International baccalaureate and um
the
the funny thing about it was is that I
hadn't seen these programs back in the
United States they were just late night
television it was this on certain
channels
and Europeans would would comment on
them about how religious Americans were
and like what it fools they were to have
televangelists and but it was obvious
that they had never seen these programs
because there wasn't much religious
about them really
they most of them they weren't really
talking much about scripture and like
they were [__] doing [__] like
singing songs and
it's like a variety show they'd have
people on that were
[__] paraplegic and [__] they
would just it was almost it was almost
kind of like Ricky Lake cross between
The Tonight Show and like Ricki Lake and
well jimin Jim and Tammy phase show for
sure was yeah but some of the other ones
were not like that like 100 Club was
more was more about scripture from what
I remember but then singing
yeah lots of singing in scripture and
then [__] like that that was the boring
one
I remember the the the the the gym and
the the PTL that's when with Jim and
Tammy Baker and [__]
that was actually entertaining I thought
it was entertaining it's not something I
watched all the time but when it when I
come across the Debbie fade be up there
[__] crying and [__] with these
[__] fake ass eyelashes and to me it
was obviously just a show I I didn't I
don't you know what I mean it was a show
that depended on audience participation
it just had kind of a church Motif to it
it was like television for religious
people
but it wasn't that religious if you
asked me well like I said their show was
yeah right um it was but not but it was
more like in a feel-good happy class but
the thing about it though is that
um some of the other shows were
absolutely just about biblical [__] and
like telling you you should hate on [__]
like that all the time and I feel like
well and and I will say that Jim Baker
um after he got out of prison which
we'll get into in a bit but um he he
started a new show he still has a show
now like with his second wife and they
went all apocalyptic at times it's like
we're selling this these fist food and
buckets and all that kind of when this
[__] was going on the most religious
person probably
uh in well I wouldn't say a religious
person in the family but this is because
my granddad on my mother's side was
[__] very super religious he was a
minister for a while
but I can remember my grandmother in
Mississippi all right when all this [__]
was going on and she didn't take any of
that [__] seriously so she didn't take
the [__] seriously I don't think anybody
took this [__] seriously I don't know I
think some people did though it was I
think it was on par with like the it was
late night shopping channels you know
what was the name of that that QVC like
QVC it was just rock bottom
entertainment uh and it was kind of like
infotainment and uh I don't know how
they sent money I guess it was through
wire transfer numbers over the phone or
credit card numbers yeah something like
that but I don't know if I could trust
them with a credit card number
you know what I mean they'd run that
[__] multiple times well of course I
wouldn't give him a [__] credit card
number well that's kind of what makes me
sad about
this whole thing is that a lot of yeah
these people are like funny and
ridiculous and stuff like that like from
our point of view but it really does
seem like they have a pretty hardcore of
True Believers who send them money and
will just forgive them no matter what
[__] up [__] they do even you can come
right up to like some people's faces
that like followed any of these
miscreants and tell them hey they just
took your money and like spent it on
hookers and blow and they basically
they'd just be like they they don't
believe it you know even if you can [__]
I don't think that's what it is I think
they don't care because like oh yeah
I've sinned too you know this is about
forgiveness if I send him money then God
will forgive me for my sins that's what
I think it was yeah I think it's
psychology more than anything else but
oh well he it's kind of like this it's
kind of like the same deal
guy comes out of prison and becomes a
preacher or a guy was a Satanist and now
he's a preacher well let's let's give
him money you know what I mean uh
because if if he can turn himself around
then that means I can turn myself around
that's what they're thinking
uh you know if you ask me so
they're they're uh projecting themselves
onto this person like uh yeah he's worse
than me and look at him he's okay
that's what I think they're doing yeah
maybe I mean like I said everyone I'm
sure has different motivations for some
people are just stupid and like I guess
I think it's like audience participation
they just have a
it's like this show you know what I mean
we got like regulars in the in the in in
got regulars in in this chat room
talking all the time they sent his buddy
I think it was very similar to that yeah
but the thing that they believed in the
the biblical angle but we're not I mean
we're not selling anything like I mean
basically we're just being like hey we
do a show and if you're entertained then
send us money that'd be cool or you
don't have to you can listen for free
that's fine yeah but it's just kind of
like we're not trying to like send me
money
um you know and we're gonna help people
there or we're gonna help these people
well yeah because I kind of feel like
it's particularly a lot of like that
Kenneth Copeland asks is like still
around who is a literal demon I think
um he looks like one crazy that that
dude's insane and I've I've watched like
a bunch of videos today like of and I
guess that's his shtick and he's
probably like embracing it because he's
like it's in tongues and [__] everybody
yeah which that's kind of a thing
because a lot of these a lot of these TV
preachers were kind of like what they
would call charismatics and that's
another thing that they would do is they
would speak in tongues which of course
is complete [__] but it makes it
sounds cool I guess yeah to a certain
things one line in the scripture and
probably take it out of context
about people speaking in tongues
well yeah they're just using one thing
that they read in there it's just like
the snake handlers like one sentence in
there and they're like hey there's an
angle that no one's before yeah let's do
that to get us to get some attention
yeah you can handle you can handle
poisonous vipers and not die
yeah I was laughing well Kenneth
Copeland um in particular like I said
they've actually in the 2000s in like
the mid-2000s
um a bunch of the Prosperity Gospel
preachers televangels and stuff like
that were investigated
um pretty much all for the same thing
because
um even though and this is stupid and I
think they should overturn this
immediately but they still haven't got
around to it yet is that I do not think
that churches should have tax exempt
status tax exempt status was I guess the
original idea for churches having that
was more to benefit smaller churches so
that they could give back to their
communities like help people that were
starving or whatever the [__] you know
when I see the mega church but that yeah
like once the mega church came and like
people were raking in like millions and
millions of dollars obviously they don't
need that [__] and now
um you have these televangelists the
Prosperity Gospel people's [__] like
Joel Osteen and Joel Osteen people like
that who have multiple properties they
look a mega church they have a house
which they consider a parsonage they
don't have to pay tax on that either and
it's like they don't have to pay tax on
it there's not really a lot of oversight
and so a lot of them will just be like
send us money we're gonna build this
church here we're gonna give all this
money to like you know these people that
are starving it and they never send that
[__] they never do what they say they're
gonna do with it yeah and even though
sadly they do get a lot of leeway that
the rest of us you know our atheist
asses don't get
um they I kind of feel like if it's so
egregious that you're I mean because Jim
Baker obviously went to prison for it
for uh wire fraud and mail fraud and
stuff like that because he was
soliciting money for projects and then
like using it for his own [__] you know
what I mean which is still illegal even
though they don't technically have to
report on like pay taxes yeah they would
just raise money for projects that were
never going to happen yeah that they
weren't going to do they were just like
like I said they just needed money for
him and they pocket that money right buy
[__] which like I said that's still
technically that's not legal even though
they do get away with a lot more than
like a regular Corporation would or a
regular non-profit that wasn't religious
they you know there's a lot more
oversight over them and the thing about
Jim Baker in particular was that
you know when he got caught later on and
we'll get into that too because it was a
sex scandal involved there too but when
he got caught for like all the wire
fraud and mail fraud and actually
eventually went to prison and he sat
there and pissed him moaned and cried
and played the victim about how oh
they're picking on me because I'm a
Christian the thing about it was I was
listening to Frontline
from like back in the 80s like from not
that long after this happened and they
said somebody was started reporting on
his [__] like all his fraud and stuff
like that back in the 70s and they sent
it to like the IRS and they sent it to
like all these like the FCC and all this
other kind of stuff and no one did Jack
[__] about it so he sits there and cry
they let him do that [__] for like eight
years before they bothered investigating
it and so for him to then come out and
say oh they're picking on me because I'm
a Christian blah blah blah I'm like dude
they let you get away with that [__] for
like eight years so shut the [__] up you
know what I mean the religious angle of
this stuff
for me I just think it was more of a
veneer yeah you had
back in his 50s and 60s
this goes all the way back to the early
1900s and here in the United States she
had traveling preachers people that
would go from one town to the next at a
local church because there wasn't much
going on the church was like the Town
Center for a lot of these places
um they would hire them on
for a Sunday or some kind of Saturday
show and he'd put on some kind of a
sermon or a show all right
and then they go they get some money
make some donations and then move along
to the next town kind of like television
this in the pre-television era
well these guys realize that [__] you
can make a living doing this and if you
ramped up your production you could kind
of gamify it and that's eventually that
led to the mega church
so a lot of the laws that the United
States had were kind of being abused the
situation had changed
now a preacher wasn't really a clergyman
he was more like an Entertainer and they
lived like an Entertainer they lived the
way a a comic lived traveling from one
club to the next staying in hotels
[__] doing his material that's
that's what a [__] motorized preacher
was like
and the Bakers were that basically
that's how they started doing puppet
shows
and that just kind of plants the seeds
because the way the the laws were kind
of said that set up it plants the seeds
where
it was easy to gamify religion
were these people really religious I
think they started off religious but as
they got more richer and more powerful I
think that was just uh that was an act
I don't think they were really religious
they've just they did too much [__] that
was against the religion well they
certainly were and the thing about it is
that it because it's become so almost a
cliche that the harder they're hammering
against oh you know how gay people are
sinful or you know against adultery or
whatever it's like you know they're
doing that that's what they're doing
yeah it's like why don't they just keep
their [__] mouth shut and yeah and in
these cases we tell it other people what
to do it's like we know that's what
you're doing they were getting busted
with male prostitutes and having
boyfriends and [__]
and uh you know the baker's Baker was
one of them you had boyfriends it's
never proven but yeah hell yeah there
were several allegations yeah
and uh he's bi and I think a lot of
these guys were
just which would be fine if they weren't
out there like actively making life
worse for people who actually are bi or
gay or whatever it's which we'll get
into because I want to talk about Ted
Haggard as well because that was their
cover that [__] nothing is but
it's bad it's like it's not good cover
though because everybody knows yeah but
you you're you're you're you're you're
you're looking at this Through The Eyes
of a rational sane person
I know they are only a sociopath can
make a living doing this and what
they're doing
sociopath's gonna rise to the top
because he'll just say anything he'll
just do you know he'll lie cheat steal
um he's he'll reap rewards from what
he's doing
it it boils down to sex money and power
that's really what Cults and this kind
of business religions are really kind of
about when you get down to him and they
fit right into it this is what this is
what they are
um
is that religion no I don't think so
it's just psychos
they just found a little a little niche
that they could get in and they just
applied their trade it's like uh what do
you call it
um
uh it's kind of like a
natural selection
that's what it is
well they're just using people's genuine
beliefs yeah you know to manipulate them
yeah into like you know yeah but
enriching themselves it's in every
industry though banking you know right
yeah I get that but everything about it
I think religion has kind of a a unique
spin on it because no protect all those
protections what you would one they have
like a lot of protections which I
absolutely do not think they should have
because a lot of this particularly mega
church or stuff like that are run
exactly like a business and I don't
understand why they're not privy to the
same I mean or they're not under the
same laws as everyone else would be if
they ran a business of that size but our
charities
uh yeah well the thing about it is that
other non-profits yeah that are not
religious yeah um you know they have to
abide by a bunch of rules yeah they have
to say like you know we have we took in
this much money and this is what we used
you know they're supposed to like
disclose how and I kind of feel like
churches get a little bit of a free pass
on that because nobody really wants to
get involved or look like they're
attacking religion even now in this day
and age and I don't think they should be
able to get away with that because
obviously they've taken massive massive
advantage and they are screwing people
out of money the thing about religion is
that
the claims that you're making are you
know ipso facto not provable
so you can say whatever [__] [__]
you want and basically like you know
give me money and you know you'll go to
heaven it's like you can't prove that
one way or the other it's not like a
company that's making a widget and you
know it's like this is the best widget
ever and you buy it and it breaks and
you're just like okay I don't like that
and I'm gonna sue you or I'm gonna like
write a bad review or something like you
have recourse I kind of feel like you
don't have as much recourse in religion
because it's all these nebulous claims
that you can't prove if you ask me the
worst one's Scientology Scientology well
yeah it's kind of the same thing I mean
it's all the same thing is the worst one
they're just using a bunch of like
[__] beliefs to like separate people
from their money and it's really sad
it's like yeah you can say that the
people that send televangles money are
dumb and maybe some of them are but
maybe some of them are really desperate
or maybe you know
they they just were raised like that and
they don't know any better or something
like that I think it's the same
demographic as people who buy off QVC
lonely old ladies in old houses and
trailers and [__]
in rural areas that's that's that's what
it is
I bet you that's it I'm sure that's what
it is Holy parachute James said it's the
same demographic that believes that
people on TV can see them in their
houses watching yeah uh yeah and uh Ben
was bringing oh Trey said uh my
grandmother and other relatives of mine
took this [__] dead serious yeah I've
known some people that did as well
um
they were talking earlier about Peter
Popoff which I actually considered like
thinking um talking about him but I
might do another show about about him in
particular because
um that was the guy who I think that was
back in the 70s who would everyone
thought he was like super amazing
because he would go around to all the
parishioners or like the people that
came there and he'd be like hey you're
so and so and you have colon cancer or
whatever and it's like you're healed of
this and blah blah and it was like holy
[__] he's [__] psychic like he knows
everything about me and then it turned
out that James Randy the magician he
found out that what would happen was
that when the people came in they would
fill out like a prayer card that had
their name and what they were there
about and blah blah and then all the
cards would go to the Peter popoff's
wife and she was behind the scenes and
she was talking to him through an
earpiece yeah and so she would just say
hey the guy that's sitting right there
as well but nobody knew that right so
when they exposed him
um the thing about it is that they they
exposed him but then again much like uh
the Energizer Bunny they just keep on
going because people were like they they
either didn't care or they just thought
people were picking on them or
persecuting him or something like that
because I think that [__] is
still around and the thing about it is
like a lot of the I was actually
surprised at how many of these
[__] are still alive for one
thing and are still doing the [__] like
maybe not to the like I said maybe not
to the extent that they were but they've
still got millions of dollars they're
still on TV they've still got their own
networks they've still got this that and
the other thing so obviously there are
still like a substantial number of
people that support them it's easier to
con a person than it is to convince them
that they've been conned well yeah they
you know [__] I mean you see that
every day but
um you you can con a person and then
[__] once they believe it somebody
else can go on because look that person
caught you oh no they didn't no oh no
that that new well people just coming to
know yeah people don't like to believe
that they have been had you know it's
you know it's embarrassing it's you know
nobody wants to not think that and then
some there's something too called the
sunk cost fallacy which Yeah the more
you invest in something like you know
the the deeper you get into it so the
more you feel like you can't back out of
it it's like I've already sent this dude
like thousands of dollars and then later
on so they just don't so so they'll just
like come up with anything like any kind
of yeah mental gymnastics to say why
that wasn't I sent Tammy thousands of
dollars and [__] got better for me you
know what I mean it's that kind of yeah
they're always kind of like trying yeah
she said the same way I've sinned it's
okay I forgive her you know God forgives
her unless to be honest Tammy favors
okay yeah she seemed like the only
decent person I'm not saying that she
didn't know about like all the fraud and
stuff she probably did no to like to
some extent yeah but out of all of these
people that I looked into she seemed
like the most decent person yeah she was
nice she was just uh she's crazy a
little bit well you know we're all crazy
it's you know I didn't want to pick on
her too hard but I mean some of the
stuff about her actually we watched um
that movie last night the eyes of Tammy
Faye which was it was a documentary that
came out in 2000 but they made a movie
uh like a fictionalized movie like based
on it and I didn't realize I watched it
on HBO Max it's really good by the way
if you haven't seen it I've been wanting
to see it for a while I didn't realize
that it was as new as it was it only
came out in 2021 and Jessica Chastain
who played Tammy face she got an Oscar
for that yeah and I think the makeup got
an Oscar too which actually I I was
thinking that when I was watching I was
like God look at the Prosthetics on her
yeah it's like that's amazing it's like
I hope this got some kind of award it
got all kind of awards yeah but uh it's
a great movie actually if you have HBO
Max yeah it's really good it's a lot of
fun
um and it's I was trying to figure out I
mean maybe I'll get into this in a bit
because I kind of wanted to talk about
Jimmy Swaggart first but
um I kind of want to figure out that
whole thing about her supposedly like
having an affair with but with that dude
and everything I didn't really like see
anything about that like in any other
kind of but maybe she talked about it
she wrote a couple Memoirs so it's like
maybe she said something about it there
better it wasn't yes it wasn't like on
her wig or her biography or anything
she made he made her confess about the
damn affair
agenda Jim did and Jim was [__] with
dudes and [__] uh and allegedly uh
sexually assaulting yeah at least one
woman yeah Jessica possibly multiple
yeah and then Jessica did a [__]
Penthouse layout I think chicken
well see I think um oh well no I think
that was the Jimmy Swagger prostitute
I'm getting them all confused now
Jessica Hahn did she was on this Howard
yeah yeah I remember I think she did she
did some [__] softcore porn
afterwards and [__] yeah well I mean the
thing about it if you get kind of like
if you get famous like that I mean you
might as well leverage the show like in
those days you had to make money even
[__] John Wayne Bobbitt his [__]
dick got cut off and then so he was
important he started making him what the
[__] else are you gonna do I mean you
know what I mean you've kind of become
the butt of a joke yeah so it's like you
might as well leverage that into some
money before before the media circus
like moves on to the next thing guess he
had to prove that his dick still worked
well yeah I'm sure that was a factor
also
Tammy said nice to see you my
mother-in-law I didn't see it either so
I don't know why maybe it didn't work
why would I don't know now I want to go
back
what's it look like if a dick gets cut
off they reattach it you know does it
work
well I guess it depends I guess it
depends like a small to tip what
happened Bob it [__] cut that man's
dick off and threw it out the [__]
car window she did yeah [__] just she
was mad have your Rod laying out there
oh see women Justified well he cheated
on her of course well I didn't say that
I said she was mad but clearly yeah the
[__] women she was
Tammy said my mother-in-law still
watches preachers on TV there are still
a lot of people that believe I live
around them yeah Ben says the whole
televangelist thing is just so
quintessentially American to the rest of
us
then John Smith said Kenneth Copeland is
a reptile in a human suit which I kind
of thought that but then I was like well
that's like an insult to reptiles
because actually I like reptiles quite a
lot and Kenneth Copeland wow I was
watching something earlier where he's he
essentially said something because his
whole thing was that he wanted to give
his um he wanted to make his
parishioners uh you know send me money
because I need another private jet and
he's got a bunch and he's got it I think
he's got his own airport too so or like
an Airfield so he's got like private jet
and they're like well he can't fly
commercial because
um he doesn't he said something like I
don't want to be in a tube with a bunch
of demons yeah okay and I was kind of
like talking about people yeah well
that's why and they said they were like
journalists saying so you think that
people who fly a commercial are demons
yeah yeah the hoi Pollo are a bunch of
demons and I was like well Christians I
mean we I don't really want to be
trapped in a tube with Kenneth Copeland
either so I guess we're on the same page
there but you know what I'm saying but I
was just kind of I mean I showed Kenneth
Copeland to my friend sod in Saudi
Arabia that dude is a [__] yeah and
he was like and Assad was horrified he
says what the hell's wrong with that guy
I am also what the hell is wrong with
that guy because that's a Christian I
said yeah yeah okay but also horrified
amorified he's insane yeah yeah the
Muslims were terrified I was watching
that I don't blame them I'm he's uh he's
a terrifying [__] person
yeah like it almost kind of looks like
and I'm not the only first person that
said this but it's like you know if if I
believe demons are real which I don't I
was like you know that if there's demons
they look just like that [__]
because like well he's like said he's on
TV and like his eyes will Flash and it's
just I've never seen anything like it
it's like a [__] evil grin Jesus
Christ it's like he's just like I was
watching a clip of him earlier where he
supposedly
um solved the pandemic by blowing it
away he blew it away with the Wind of
God yes right yeah yeah somebody [__]
songified that made a video was great
yeah there's a lot of like I think
Kenneth Copeland is probably the most
memed because he's the craziest like he
just says all kind of like crazy [__]
[__] and like just the way there was
also I saw this one clip of him earlier
where he was doing that healing thing
yeah and he straight up knocked over a
dude in a wheelchair and the dude in the
wheelchair is like laying there like
um you know I can't and then he tries to
like play and then Kenneth Copeland
tries to play it off help him up help
him up God's all over him and the dude's
kind of like
um I can't get up
I've seen clips of copper so freaking
out on stage with with his religious
henchmen and even they are shocked at
some of the [__] that he does and he
starts [__] speaking in tongues and
it's just ridiculous and they're looking
at him like okay there you go okay dude
his tongues you know man it's second
yeah drugs are bad kids I mean and he
looks like uh he looks like Alfred E
Newman if you guys know what Mad
Magazine is he looks like a dark-haired
old Alfred E Newman it's [__] crazy
and he's got to be
80s I mean yes
with jet black hair you know that that's
a [__] wig he's got a [__] wig on
all right but he's playing it off plus
it kind of looks like his somebody put
their foot on his head pulled his skin
up and stapled it
I'm just saying it kind of looks like a
trip
Ben said I used to play Kenneth Copeland
on my computer when I went out to scare
away burglars and one of my neighbors
asked if I had an American stick with me
that's awesome I mean hopefully please
like people in other countries do not
think that all Americans are like
Kenneth Copeland now more of them are
than I would like you know but that dude
is he's crazy he's in a Class by Himself
I mean we all think he's crazy too most
of us see this is the thing man I always
think that that's more entertainment
than anything else
you know people that watch that I think
they're just being entertained
I mean yeah they're sending me money but
I don't think it has anything to do with
religion
I think they're religious or they think
that they are
but he's not talking about any Scripture
religion really that I know of it's just
he's pulling that [__] all out of his
ass it's just the big
show
you know it's crazy and whoever's
watching that will just go right along
with it yeah yeah yeah yeah the wind of
God yeah blowing the code of it away
yeah yeah the heat will get it you know
and but he well he's kind of more like
apocalypse yeah because he's more
talking about like how much gays suck
and like you know markets with his
people these people are demons and Mark
of the beasts and all that kind of crazy
so like I said it's like you have some
that are more like Jim and Tammy Faye
which I kind of feel like you don't see
much of that anymore now you have to be
like super extreme like to get attention
so I kind of feel like most of the ones
nowadays are like everyone sucks
well because you get um Tammy face said
you shouldn't be picking on gay people
well see that's what I was gonna say
that's what's actually kind of cool
about Tammy Faye like I said I'm not
saying she didn't know about all the
fraud and [__] like that because I'm
sure she did you know I'm not excusing
her for that but um she was actually at
a time during the 80s like in the early
to mid 80s when if you were alive back
then
um you know but because AIDS had just
become like a big thing and so everyone
was very like there was a lot of like
homophobic rhetoric and like people were
trying to call it the gay cancer and all
this other kind of crap and people were
like flipping out about it it's like
there was that whole thing about that
kid that got AIDS from like a blood
transfusion or something and everyone
was freaking I don't want him at my
school all these disease blah blah and
like all this other kind of crap it was
horrible well yeah so so okay so the
thing about that was that Tammy Faye in
the midst of all that she at least had
the [__] ovaries to have a gay man on
her show who had AIDS and he was a
Christian and he was a yeah he was a
pastor actually and
um She interviewed him like for over
like uh you know tell TV yeah and
actually like was quite understanding
but like asking him about like when did
you know you were gay and like when did
you find out and I guess his um they
didn't they didn't say this in the movie
but um his uh partner had died of it and
so she like asked him about that and she
was actually like really compassionate
and then she told the audience she's
like you know how can we call ourselves
Christians if we are like scared of them
if we're you know like scared that we're
gonna catch something or something like
that it's like we should love everybody
like he says God loves you like Jesus
said yeah and she just likes God loves
everybody the way they are which I was
like you know if more Christians were
like that maybe they wouldn't be so
[__] she knew the gym was gay
he might have been gay she was the beard
probably to make him seem straight I got
a feeling [__] Jim Baker was good
yeah well he was making a move on just
gone to bye yeah yeah
just John Smith said Tammy Faye has
become a bit of a gay icon yeah uh she
weirdly
um well the thing about it when she was
dying of cancer there was a lot of she
did get a lot of support in the gay
community because like I said she was
one of the earliest and coming from uh
from um you know a corner of the culture
that you wouldn't think that it would be
coming from
um you know she actually kind of stood
up for them and told everybody to quit
picking on him and so uh later on like
when she was you know kind of had become
something of a parody of herself and
become kind of a joke
um actually the gay community actually
sort of rallied to her defense I think
like even in the um the documentary that
they made about her in 2000 or 2001 or
whatever it was like RuPaul uh narrated
that documentary so yeah so she
remembered they called her the original
drag queen yeah
yeah she was yeah she kind of wants to
be honest she had mental problems man
she did but you know what I mean I feel
kind of bad for her though
um but I can I can understand because
you know growing up in the age scare
they had everybody terrified of [__]
age they did yeah you know y'all think
the [__] this young people growing up
in covid like you know scared a coat
that was [__] compared to what they were
doing to us with AIDS they had me
convinced that everyone would eventually
get AIDS we are we were all gonna die
and they weren't really sure I remember
that nobody's really sure how you caught
it that you could catch it a million
different ways you might be able to
catch it by sitting down on toilet seat
and just all kinds of I remember hearing
that too yeah you know they weren't
nobody was really sure how you could
catch it and like what happens if
somebody's preparing food and some of
them AIDS particles falls off of them it
gets in the food yeah you never know
AIDS part of AIDS dust you know you
don't know you didn't know because they
weren't real clear on it
and I think they were not clear on
purpose I think because people were
making money off of it making money off
of AZT and [__] without you involved in
all that no I think it's more a case of
what uh what holy Parish of Doom just
said got to keep Americans terrified at
all times yeah I just make money yeah I
just kind of feel like uh fearful people
and I was gonna say this earlier fearful
people are uh and easily manipulated
people
um and social control I think I was what
was I watching I was watching um oh as I
think I mentioned before Dr Grande and
he did a couple like on YouTube he's
really he's really funny and he actually
did a video uh psychoanalyzing Jim Baker
and he also did one for Ted Haggard
which I want to talk about a little bit
but I think on the Jim Baker one he said
something like really insightful because
he said Jim Baker like after you know
they had this big thing with the PTL
Ministry and apple and he ended up
having to go to prison and blah blah and
then when he got back out and he started
his show up again the first thing he
went into was like apocalyptic like you
know Jesus is like the end of the world
it's Armageddon blah blah and it's like
and he's kind of like made a niche for
himself that way and he's like it's a
lot easier to sell people fear than it
is Hope oh it's more interesting
I yeah I mean I guess when I was a kid
man I used to love anything having to do
with like [__] the apocalypse you
know what I mean Man Who Saw tomorrow
and Orson Welles you know talking about
you know the [__] tiger in the blue
turban and looking fire raining down on
a new city and then you can even put
some like you know uh uh freaking [__]
from revelations in there I just thought
that was cool as [__] you know loved it
like I said I want to make I want to
make a Revelations movie now
what is it about human psychology like
not everybody because I don't really
have this but I kind of feel like a lot
of humans they have some kind of weird
morbid fascination with destruction with
destruction like at the end of the world
like they it's almost like they want it
like they welcome it
that's what I'm saying it seems to be
something like
inbound in like most human psychology
like I said I don't think I really I
don't really have that mindset but a lot
of people do I think it comes from
civilizations that have large
populations
they have to work hard to sustain
themselves there's a bunch of problems
and this way the mesoamerica was with
the Aztec empire
the average person is sitting around
like man this shit's gotta end sometimes
this shit's gotta end it can't go on
like this that's probably what it is
this [__] sucks man
I mean the only reason the only reason I
would want that to happen was so I
wouldn't have to pay off all my credit
cards yeah yeah right
yeah and it would be like a lot quieter
because most of the people would be dead
so that would be nice Mexicans were
Mexicans were worried about paying off
the blood debt you know to so you know
paying off a blood debt was [__] much
worse than credit cards so you know it
was a totalitarian theocracy so and
really I know it has to happen you know
really I don't like I don't you know and
I wouldn't want that seriously because
why the [__] would I want that the
Soviet Union went through that they only
were around for 70 years man a lot of it
bad for [__] styling and all those
guys and they just [__] killed so
many people just through starvation and
mismanagement and circular fires Squad
and blaming the cool locks and [__]
all kinds of [__] eventually people just
like oh [__] this I want no part of this
they lied to us they lie to us they
continue to lie and [__] we know
they're lying to us and they know that
we know that they're lying to us and yet
we still pretend to believe you know a
[__] like that there was that kind of
situation they were just sick of it it
was man one day [__] woke up was on
duty [__] got up out of my bunk and
they would go Ross man the Soviet Union
collapsed like what and so it's dude
it's gone the Army's Vanishing I
remember when that [__] was going on and
they were showing it on [__]
television it was after the fall Berlin
wall and we had something that our whole
Army was trained to combat this [__]
machine you know this and they were good
the the that was [__] about that the
Russians weren't any good the Russians
were [__] good they were real good
they still are good
and it just evaporated because they they
stopped believing they just stopped
obeying
amazing
amazing it's Army just evaporated in
about two but like I said you never know
like what's gonna happen no like that
that's why I think it's silly getting
all getting your panties and a Twist
it's all about it's like oh it's like
the signs at the end of the world and
this is going to happen and that's you
don't [__] know nobody knows but I
was saying each culture has an end time
kind of philosophy well yeah I know the
Soviets weren't we're atheists pretty
much
and that was their version of the
Apocalypse you know that it just
vanished there it went what do they call
that eschatology eschatology I don't
know I want to say I don't know if I'm
if that's the right word but it's like
yeah like all cultures have
this kind of weird inbuilt yeah
self-destruct self-destruct kind of
fantasy yeah like very very common
that's what like I kind of feel like
that's the basis of a lot of religions
yeah the Mexican religion was like that
basically it was one big end times
prophecy and worrying about the the
Mayan long cow and yeah time worshipers
and stuff and the return of cuckoo con
and yeah
uh Zach says I still say Tom will love
the last of us we should get around to
watching because I've heard it's like
really really good I thought about it
last night but it was like getting late
and I wanted to watch eyes of Tammy
faces
um all right so I let's what let's get
into the show then yeah I mean we've
already kind of been into it like I said
we'll just be kind of loose what I
wanted to do
um I was kind of interested a little bit
in not necessarily a history of
televangelism but just like a couple
facts about that I found out that I were
kind of interesting and then you know
just like a couple minor sort of [__]
scandals and then I wanted to get into
Jimmy Swaggart and then I wanted to get
into Jim and Tammy Faye Baker and then
Ted Haggard like I said I was gonna do
more than that but it's like I don't
want the show to be like five hours long
because you know I have to get up early
uh so what's that kind of thing uh John
Smith said the Celts thought the world
would end when the sky fell down yeah
yeah when that [__] Falls it's over bro
yep we're all just gonna smoosh yeah and
the stars fall from the sky that's
another really good one man the stars
fall from the sky and you walk up and
pick one up ain't that something and
it's this yeah
how much are they worth can we sell
these yeah imagine that they're like
little diamonds these little diamonds in
in the foundation the fundament of the
sky it's a dome like I said somebody
says fundament I always thinking
somebody's taint yeah yeah watch the
tanks of the Universe I don't know why I
don't know why tournament is a
foundation I know that but I don't know
why that word became associated with a
taint I don't know it's ridiculous it
must be I don't know maybe it has a
different definition or something I
don't remember like where I made that
Association every time somebody says
that word
the fundament the foundation of the sky
man [__] they're saying it's got a
ceiling it's a dome and there's stars
and planets set in Houston Astrodome and
that's some [__] it's holes like
pinholes in the curtain of the sky yeah
and it peels back
Angels come back construction paper up
there yeah with a company maybe but then
they fall from the sky it starts to fall
from the sky laying everywhere you can
go pick them up
put them in a bottle and take them home
and use it to light up your house
so the anxious are thinking yeah I mean
they were probably calculating what
would one be worth you know
I mean to be fair what's the market for
the ancient people weren't the sharpest
knives
they didn't know any better I don't know
I think they did
the Greeks already knew by that time
yeah I mean the atmosphere
I mean you would be actually be
surprised at what the ancient types like
not everybody most of the people were
just Rubes and illiterate and stuff but
it's like educated people new educated
people knew that stuff like thousands of
years yeah they already figured out the
diameter of the Sun and how far away the
[__] moon was and all that math
[__] yeah they figured geometry and
math
says Jehovah's Witnesses told their
followers the end of the world was going
to happen in 1975 that's right uh and
most of them sold everything yeah a lot
of them did they literally thought it
would happen well there was that whole
thing um I don't think we ever did a
show about it but I think we brought it
up when we did uh because I think we did
a show about like ooh end of the world
or whatever and I think we talked about
the Miller rights yeah
um who yeah they thought the world was
going to end in what I want to say 1836
but I could be totally wrong on that
they tried twice they yeah well and then
they all went they sold all their [__]
and then they like went up to the top of
this hill and were like Jesus is coming
and then they're like well is Jesus
coming it must be next year this is
taking forever and I sold all my [__]
now what am I getting they said it was
gonna be next year yeah oh whoops I got
the date right yeah my bad we forgot to
subtract a year for leap year I let my
favorite thing about that whole uh [__]
show was that they called it the great
disappointment yeah
which I'm like yeah that's probably
pretty disappointing all right we sat up
here for like 24 hours and jack [__]
happened and it's like probably they
were really mad well probably they
weren't though because
like I said the
um I think I said this before but I'm
pretty sure it was Carl Sagan but he
talked about people that have these
beliefs and these particular like
particular religions or anything like
that and it's like the more like you
give them all this evidence against like
you know oh the end of the World's Gonna
Come and then it doesn't and then it's
like oh it's gonna come next week and
then it doesn't and then it's like but
it's like they still keep believing it
and it's like he calls them Unsinkable
rubber ducks because they just keep
they just keep believing the [__] even
after like Time After Time After Time
it's just that now just insinkable Ducks
yeah yeah
and it's like I said it just gets to a
point where you're so invested in the
[__] whether monetarily or emotionally
or whatever it is and you can't you feel
like you can't back out a bit so it's
like no matter what Revelations come out
about it you just have to justify it
somehow you have to do some kind of like
mental gymnastics or like you know
compartmentalize or do something to say
that it's like well that's not really
what's happening or somebody's picking
on us or they're making it up or
something like that it always has to be
some excuse you know what I mean
uh John Smith the great disappointment
will be the title of the autobiography
either that or where did I go right yeah
Archimedes was trying to work out the
shape of the universe yeah that's like I
said they have their [__] together back
then like Archimedes was [__] making
mechanical computers that you wouldn't
see anything like that until the 1920s
yeah he figured some [__] out yeah he
figured some [__] out they were just
right there toward an industrial
revolution and it happened would be two
thousand three thousand years ahead two
thousand years ahead yeah yeah imagine
that
we'd have been on a moon [__] what
900 years
ago gone to the moon like hundreds and
hundreds of years yeah one thousand
eight hundred years ago they're still on
the moon that would have been crazy we'd
have been [__] living on there by now
God damn it I feel cheated I'm telling
you people
do an extensive survey of the Moon
that's been there a long time
long enough for the earth to [__]
recycled itself several times all right
there might be something there that
might be trillions of years old or
billions of years old there might be
something there left from a
ancient alien civilization long gone but
it was from here on Earth that'd be
something else before the dinosaurs and
everything before trilobites
imagine that yeah there were like some
way ancient like just way back Earth
beings that went up there to the moon
and honey for a little while yeah it
might be I feel like the remains of a
city up there wouldn't that be something
I would check at the polls I mean I'll
believe it when I see one of those holes
might have something buried on it
because all I see now is like oh it's a
face all on my own except not yeah
that's not that's not
the face is on an American thing in
Brazil it's a rabbit
that's what they call it see just like
looking at the [__] clouds and say
that that's some paradolia right there
yeah the Brazilians say it's a rabbit in
the Moon
if you look at it it does look like a
rabbit yeah I guess no I was talking
about oh I was thinking of the face on
Mars oh that's what I was thinking of
okay
um all right so I was confusing my
Planet
yeah there's a rabbit in the moon see to
me it's like when I was a kid there was
like the man in the morning like that is
not a [__] man it doesn't look like a
man it doesn't look like a sorta unless
he's got a black eye like somebody
punched him somebody punched in there
well that was just like that or that was
like an old one of the early silent
films yeah this is George melie yeah I
think that's it a trip to the moon I
think it was called and he had the like
that thing in the thing yeah and I was
like oh so I'm not the only one that
looks thanks to Man in the Moon looks
like he has a big [__] black guy
uh but yeah
so I don't know I kind of find this
interesting because I feel like every
new technology that comes along
usually the earliest adopters
um well the earliest adopters are pretty
much every new technology are porn I'm
sorry but that's just how it happened
um and I think probably not television I
guess but I mean most new technologies
like film and everything like that and
photography it's usually porn is the
usually the first thing however I will
say that um obviously uh you know
Evangel evangelism is nothing new it's
you know back in the day they used to
have to do it
on foot or on donkey or whatever they
just would go like from town to town and
you know and I guess they still did that
like even though after technology
existed
and whatnot but I just kind of feel like
uh the Christian evangelicals
were actually one of the earliest
adopters of radio like when radio
started to get really big like in the
1920s
so um you actually have uh churches as
early as the 1920s like having their own
radio stations and then you had probably
one of the earliest I don't know if I
would call her Prosperity Gospel but Amy
simple McPherson who we should probably
do a show about one of these days
because she's kind of a fascinating
historical figure but she was one of the
first uh she was like a tent revivalist
and she also started on the radio and
was wildly successful and was actually
one of the first if not the first
evangelists to
kind of draw a lot of criticism for
making a [__] ton of money
um off of her followers
um you know where she would get like
interviewed in there be like how can you
justify because at that point I kind of
feel like people still thought of
Christianity as like you know Jesus
being poor and like everyone's supposed
to be like giving up your stuff and
everything like that so this whole thing
about preaching and making all this
money off people and living this really
lavish lifestyle which Amy uh which Amy
McPherson did I kind of feel like people
were still like really uncomfortable
with that and I guess like even nowadays
like some Christians are uncomfortable
with it as as you can see as uh with
criticisms of Prosperity Gospel still
because that's not really
the beliefs that are espoused by people
like Joel Osteen and stuff like that
that's not really what they would call
like traditional Christianity which like
I said is usually kind of more
less focused on the material Prosperity
Gospel is basically like
um you know we God wants you to be rich
and if you listen to what we say and
send us all this money you can live like
we live and so they almost want to
become an advertisement for
for that for wealth so they're very like
conspicuous about it and I kind of feel
like that's why they a lot of the times
that's why they get a lot of um Flack
even nowadays Kenneth Copeland got that
Joel Osteen got that and stuff like that
because these dudes are like Creflo
Dollar that's another guy
um who who go around with these like you
know thousand dollar suits and like
private jets and pimp style Christianity
right it's that's essentially what it is
and I think like a lot of people have
It's Like a Prayer It's Like a Prayer
freaking pyramids the scheme yeah you
give us money and pray and [__] then
the money will come to us and prayers
will come to you and get some other
people to pray and then just keep keep
the money flowing and we'll all get rich
together
that's a good idea
does it work I don't know probably not
no they get rich you don't well send
some people some like brochures on how
to invest in real estate and [__] there
ought to be there ought to be a way to
where they'd start loaning money back to
people that'd be good make it like a bag
I'm sure some of them have thought of
that angle yeah but that's the thing and
remember like um I think I was talking
about this dude before but Robert Tilton
now interestingly I don't think he's had
any uh sex scandals that I know of but
one of his big things and I don't know
why this was scandalous because I feel
like this was probably what you should
have expected
his big thing like I said was he would
tell you like give out of your need like
send me a thousand dollars and then God
will like pay you back like tenfold or
whatever it was that was like his big
thing and so you would have to send the
money in like an envelope with your
prayer request and he would send you
like these little [__] prayer cloths
and all this other kind of [__] and they
found out later on that he was basically
just opening the letters taking the
checks out and not even like reading the
prayer requests and I'm like why is that
surprising he was just throwing them
away gotta read it
because they found him all in a dumpster
gotta read it don't worry about it and
people were like shocked I was like why
are you shocked that's like exactly he's
like he doesn't give a [__] he just
watched your checks man that's all they
wanted but that dude I don't think he's
stolen right he'd do something like a
normal priest would they'd pile up all
the prayers and go Lord answer all these
prayers and yeah all right we're covered
you were covered okay yeah God knows
what they say you guys know what they
say he's gonna handle it
[Laughter]
so you know that's how they would get
away with it yeah that's what I would do
well yeah they always do they have to
they always have to [__] put them all
put all the prayers over here they
always have to have a [__] all right
y'all ready all right
stand back
got out of there and God go ahead
start speaking in tongues
Elohim God most high L Elohim
you read all this [__] for us
thank you very much y'all take care yeah
like [__] saying I have left the
building
I mean yeah
uh but yeah so
um so during the 20s and 30s like
particularly after the Great Depression
and everything like that you had like a
lot of
I feel like the Great Depression because
it was so widespread and it was so you
know people were desperate and stuff
like that so obviously a lot of people
were turning to religion to make
themselves feel better so there was kind
of like a Resurgence of like the Tent
Revival movement and that kind of
translated also into like a lot more
preachers on the radio now interestingly
even though they did have like people
did have TV in the 30s it wasn't that
widespread
but I kind of feel like TV
um religion on TV didn't really take off
until like the 1950s and interestingly
if you ever get asked this if you're
ever on Jeopardy or anything like that
and people want to know like who's
widely considered like the first
quote-unquote televangelist uh it was a
dude named Fulton J Sheen he had been on
the radio for 20 years and then in 1951
uh he actually had a TV show and is I
don't know if it's like if he's
universally considered the first
televangelist but he's for sure like you
know pretty widely considered like the
first televangelist
um and then in 1957 you had Oral Roberts
who was still around in the 1980s
and he got like super super famous and
then uh you had in 1961 you had the
Christian Broadcasting Network CBN
founded by Pat Robertson uh which is
still around and we're kind of like
going to talk about that a little bit
because uh that was what the channel
That hosted the uh 700 Club which is
still on there like I said even nowadays
and they said as of according to
Wikipedia as of 2016 the 700 Club one of
the oldest shows on American television
obviously because it's been on since
1961 and was broadcast in 39 languages
in in 138 countries at least as of the
modern day
so I kind of feel like so 60s 70s and
80s kind of like the Heyday for
televangelism
um a lot of it was
spurred I guess because of the one the
popular to Billy Graham who was like
hugely hugely famous and I think he kind
of um inspired a lot I don't know if he
had any scandals Billy Graham he seemed
like one of the only ones that didn't
have them maybe somebody can correct me
if I'm wrong but I don't remember
hearing any like really high profile
scandals about Billy Graham but pretty
much all the other ones though had it
but yeah you got you had Oral Roberts
had Jimmy Swaggart like I said Jim and
Tammy Faye Jerry Falwell first of all
the motherfucker's name is oral yeah
okay I'm already in suspicious
who would who would name their I mean
that's a terrible name somebody didn't
know what what it meant I mean it'd be
like name your kid anal I mean it's I'm
sure it's fine like in another country
where like if they don't speak English
but in the English language that's not
really a great thing to name your kid oh
and it's weird that they spelled it like
oral like o-r-a-l like the word I have
seen the name oral or o-r-e-l yeah but
which is I mean it's just semantics
because it's pronounced the same but
it's spelled differently this is my son
oral this is my daughter anal yeah
laughs
do with them as you wish I know right
damn
[__] crazy Ben said all the big
televangelists went to Oral Roberts
University yeah they did Ted Haggard
went there too which we'll get into that
a little bit you had to get your star
that's how you had to get your fake
degree yeah but uh I mean I guess it's a
real degree in the sense that it's on a
real piece of paper and stuff yeah but I
don't know if it necessarily means
anything like I don't know if you're
joining the club I don't know if they
teach you anything well Oral Roberts
universe or maybe I'm thinking of
Liberty University which was I think
that was falwell's thing wasn't it I
don't know that and that had like super
super strict rules like you can for a
while uh I think it was Liberty
University for a while they were whites
only well up into the 1970s maybe the
1980s until they started getting in
trouble
um about it and then even then they were
like very reluctant uh to let people
that weren't white into Liberty
University so they they were not big on
desegregation
um so that was so there was that and
even nowadays because I think it's still
around
um
you can't they they have like no dating
no dancing no I mean they're super super
strict and I think like like last I
heard because I was watching a
documentary about it
um that was just from last year and I
think they have 4 500 students but the
problem about it is that they it costs a
lot of money to go there I think they
said it was like 23 000 a year and
that's just tuition that's like not room
aboard or any of that stuff and despite
that um the the university is
essentially like ins insolvent so
they're like um gonna have to file for
bankruptcy because the thing about it is
that even though these talents this has
happened to Jim and Tammy Faye Baker as
well is that even that they rake in like
[__] tons of cash they spend [__] tons
of cash too and a lot of times they're
using some Creative Accounting to make
it look like they're not spending [__]
tons of cash and they're not really like
there's no oversight so a lot of times
they're like yeah we pulled in five
million dollars last month but we spent
like 10 million you know what I mean
like on this [__] on hookers and
blow and yeah you know and gold-plated
toilet seats and crap like that you know
what I mean so so I kind of feel like
that's that's one of the things that uh
caused the baker's downfall for sure and
I think that was one of the things I
don't know what the exact case is in
Liberty University but I do know that
they're having some problems and have to
like file for bankruptcy even though
they have like a bunch of students
and they pay a lot of money but I don't
know why you'd want to go there because
it sounds like the least fun place on
Earth but you know on paper at least
whatever who knows what's actually going
on yeah they might be super free
I don't know be like [__] Vacation
Bible Camp when I was a little kid went
to those things they was [__]
it was [__] fest not for us but the the
counselors were all [__] teenagers
man yeah they were [__] [__] up
looking back on it
the kids are making out too well yeah I
mean that's just a vacation kids yeah
Vacation Bible Camp it didn't have
anything to do with Bible
it was just let's get away well yeah I
kind of feel like that kind of thing I
mean unless your family is like super
hardcore and they have their own like
really like super hardcore thing
Vacation Bible Camp I even knew some
kids who their parents weren't
particularly religious they were just
like they're just like well we couldn't
get him in a secular one so we'll just
send them this you know they'll just go
make some God's eyes out of popsicle
sticks and run around in canoes and [__]
Easter egg hunts yeah it'll be a [__]
campfire they'll sing some songs about
Jesus yeah and then [__] then they're
all making out
they're like 11 making out with each
other they're really they were that
young making out with each other well
that's not that weird yeah I mean as
long as everyone's 11 and it's not like
yeah yeah no 11 year old and like the 40
year old camera then we've got a problem
11 12 they're all making out
Ben says one of Billy Graham's grandsons
was accused of cheating on his spouse
that seems to be as bad as a guest yeah
that's one thing it's Billy Graham is
really the only one that I can only one
of these type of people that I can think
of that didn't have some kind of like
horrible Scandal whether it was
Financial sexual or both he seems to be
as squeaky clean as he appears to be
which is unusual because none of them
are you know what I mean like almost to
a man they're just like the [__]
vilest people imaginable but they'll
come out and you know holier than thou
and this and that and the other and
[__] on people for doing doing drugs and
being gay and [__] like that and they're
doing all that [__] which like I said I
don't I don't
I don't do as long as everyone's
concerning adults it's the hypocrisy I
don't like that's why that's why I don't
like these people
because they say one thing and do
another
you know that's what irritates me about
it yeah I think I think in a lot of the
cases
their Inner Circle knows what's going on
and then to deny it they have to
denounce it
so that's what they're doing I think
well I kind of want to get the inner
circle kind of suspects what the [__]
this dude's doing and these guys well I
gotta convince them that I'm not gay so
they cut us out there and [__] get
some fire breathing serve sermon about
the sins of [__] the Flesh and men
shouldn't be laying with other men as if
they were women and he's [__] doing
all this [__] you know and he's trying
to
he's trying to hide
that's boyfriend standing there which
all you said is dumb because it's like
everybody like well at least most
intelligent people are like oh well
obviously that means you're doing that
because you wouldn't be [__] crying
about it so much they're not that
intelligent though I guess not and
because it's really transparent yeah and
then the and then the uh the upper ranks
of the church have a vested interest in
that [__] not getting out because
they're all making money hand over fist
so of course they're not gonna [__]
go come on man we know about you come on
they're not gonna do that oh well well
wait until we get into this okay yeah it
does happen because it does happen but
but you know they're not going to do it
on television until they get really
[__] pissed off for that maybe get
maybe they have an opportunity to take
over that's another thing too
because uh if you're the head of a damn
religion
religious Empire that's making a [__]
ton of money you're also a Target just
ask [__] L Ron Hubbard you know what
I mean
people are going to take over after
after you're gone you know like Miss
cabbage and Miss cabbage [__] sank a
lot of people just so he could inherit
the throne to become cob of [__]
Scientology
you know I'm gonna say that some of the
[__] about L Ron Hubbard's death is kind
of [__] suspicious I mean I think he
was dying
but there's a chance people may have
helped him along you know
John Smith says Oral Roberts University
Girls Gone Wild she's showing all of her
ankle
then he said turns out an open grift
attracts bad people who knew yeah
exactly this definitely this this kind
of scam really does attract the worst
the worst kind of people the worst don't
be stereotyping Church girls man Church
girls were wild Church girls are naughty
they're just making a he's just they
just they just do it a different way but
they're doing stuff
yeah like I said it depends on what is
going on yeah it depends on church but
yeah
so uh so yeah
so I feel like after
televangelism kind of I feel like it
kind of hit its peak in the 80s and then
because of all the scandals sort of like
snowballing then after that it sort of
became like a little bit of a joke but
it absolutely did not go away it's still
around nowadays like I said the 700 Club
is still on Jim Baker's still around
um Jimmy Swaggart is still around all
these [__] are still alive the
only one that's dead is Tammy Faye and
she died of cancer a long time ago but
it's like all the other these other
[__] are still going around
still on the grift
um and people are still sending the
money so you know I guess they didn't
really go anywhere which is crazy but
like I said it's not it's not as up in
the you know in the culturals I guess I
guess anymore but it is uh still around
so um so yeah so like I said in the
mid-2000s uh they actually did do there
was like a sort of a government
investigation a little bit like a
senator that looked into a lot of these
Prosperity Gospel things because like I
said a lot of them were griffs or they
were all kind of like different scandals
having to do with it and
um Kenneth Copeland and his wife Gloria
they got brought up mostly they were
brought up because
um they they had a thing where they
would collect all this money like oh
give us all this relief like disaster
relief for Haiti like when they had
those bad hurricanes and all that other
kind of stuff and um
and then they they collected millions of
dollars and then never sent it like they
used it on their own [__] like bought a
private jet or whatever the [__] with it
also they were
um threatened with well I don't know if
they actually threatened but they they
were talking about maybe revoking their
tax exempt status because you know if
you're not American you can churches
have tax exempt status but if you start
uh essentially like doing political [__]
like from your church like you're
telling people who to vote vote for um
you know for example then um you the IRS
will threaten to take your taxes and
Status away because we're supposed to
have separation of church and state in
theory uh it doesn't usually work out
that way but um so Kenneth Copeland I
guess had when Mike Huckabee was running
was what a candidate
um he had him on his show like a whole
bunch of times and was like openly
talking about the [__] so they were
talking about taking his tax exempt
status away because you're not supposed
to mix the two things but they never did
because they never do anything to any of
these people they're energizing about
church girls look man [__] the poop
hole loophole yeah yeah talk about
church
um
if you actually look at the details a
lot of those and this has been going on
for a long time a lot of those top name
famous
or you know notable adult actresses
they're Mormons ex-mormons or ex
Jehovah's Witness is pretty common
between them the real religious families
well I mean yeah if you grew up like
that you probably want to like go the
complete opposite way too you know yeah
I get it
I get it like I said I guess I didn't
really have
um I wasn't a real rebellious kid
because I didn't have to be like my
parents weren't you know they weren't
like oppressing me Man or anything like
that they were just kind of like I think
a lot of it is is that you know
those are strict religions and those
girls run from them yeah and uh they
kind of end up in a [__] bad place in
life they don't maybe don't have the
means of support their families not
supporting them you know or helping them
survive so they end up in a in a sex
trade
unfortunately but uh you know if they're
cute I think Belladonna was Mormon
uh remember Belladonna yeah and she was
a Mormon
um but I just over the years I've
noticed that a lot of
a lot of uh Mormons and um Jehovah's
Witness pop up a lot in the in the
background so those girls
Ben says churches in the U.S register
for tax-free status with a 301c or
something yeah that's right and the IRS
then threatens to revoke it they are of
course free to tell people how to vote
but donating his other matter yeah
that's um so I I kind of feel like
they're not really there's there's all
kind of like gray area and usually like
I said and this happened with the Jim
and Tammy Faye thing too and because in
particular Jim and Tammy Faye I think
they went into this a little bit in the
movie and like the documentary that I
watched where even though
um allegations actually proof of
wrongdoing Financial wrongdoing had been
brought to the attention of the IRS the
FCC like various other Bodies In the
late 1970s nobody really did anything
about it and then in 1980 when Ronald
Reagan got arrested um got erected got
already got elected gross and he's
erecting himself that's that's gross but
um that's almost as bad as like you
asked me to like picture Kenneth
Copeland having sex with somebody yeah
but um you know what I mean it's like
Kenneth Copeland in his own porn scene
Grody and it's a solo seed I'm sure
somebody's done a deep fake of that like
I'm not gonna look because I don't want
to see it because
I don't I don't need that image in my
brain Jesus Christ I can already like
imagine it and I'm just like no thank
you but um but yeah but because Reagan
was you know had a large portion of like
two-thirds of evangelicals or something
that like voted for him so he was like
real buddy buddy with like a lot of the
televangelists at the time who would
help to like deliver some votes to him
so he when he put a new guy into like
the head of the FCC they didn't say it
outright but they went super easy on
like a lot of churchy stuff they're just
like well we're just not gonna We're not
gonna pick on them so they kind of got
away with a lot of [__] so like I
said the The Bakers in particular got
away with [__] for like eight years
before anybody got off their ass and
like was like oh my God there's like
this big huge report of like all these
Financial
missed dealings that they had done that
everybody knew about like back then but
they didn't like investigate it even
though they should have that haircut
looks good on you on camera thanks yeah
it was good don't you guys like her
haircut I think it looks good yeah yeah
um Ben says atheists here get very
frustrated when they find out churches
don't need any sort of government permit
or license to exist and not pay tax they
only need one to certify marriages
yeah I mean I'm not a big fan of this
tax-exempt thing
um I honestly if they run it like a
business then they should be taxed like
a business they should be taxed like and
you know just like anybody else would be
I mean it was originally for like little
small like I said church house you know
which fine but um you know like I said
provided that you're
like I said I kind of feel like the
original intention of that like back in
the old days when they first established
that was that sometimes particularly out
in the frontier or you know the Midwest
or places where there wasn't a lot of
government services then the
understanding was that the church would
provide some of those services that the
government was not available to provide
to people that were poor or something
like that well look at this so you know
and that's fine if that was what was
going on look at the Catholic Church
they're tax-free here right that's
ridiculous yeah there's no way [__]
Empire man there is no way that should
be Vatican has its own bank there is no
way governments obviously [__] money
in and they own more real estate than
God and like [__] super
expensive real estate you know I mean
the
no the Catholic church needs to pay
taxes in the United States that's what I
mean yeah I mean that's
that's a 2 000 year old [__] real
estate Empire they have all the [__]
money they got a [__] ton of money they
don't even need to grow they can just
sit there and be rich
you know Meanwhile my broke ass got to
pay taxes yeah businesses got to pay
taxes or landlords they're massive
landlords they can just sit there and
just [__] make money forever they
have the Vatican bank which is well
known
for laundering money don't you do
the CIA laures its money it's black
budget inside that [__] bank it's
just I don't know it makes me mad that
they're treated differently
I mean it should just be true that's the
same it should be treated the same as
any other business Enterprise because
that's what it is just you're selling a
service you're selling a service just
like any other service it needs to be
paid in their fair share they need to be
pulling their weight there's no reason
why they should think of all the extra
money that this country would have if
they would just tax the [__] churches
for the sake you know you don't tax
Little Mom and Pop churches or nothing
like that I'm just the mega churches
yeah yeah I mean they've got the money
once you break a certain amount you
should be paying taxes yeah exactly I
mean you know kind of contribute back to
the country that let you make all this
[__] money you parasite I'm just
saying
don't make the rest of us little people
[__] pain Jenny was saying the
original the original intent was like
little bitty Community right like like a
community service type of thing to keep
them tax-free right that's fine once you
have a certain amount of [__] assets
and you're once you have a certain
amount of Revenue going through you then
no it shouldn't be the deal
you're learning it like you have your
own [__] satellite service that's
what I mean and particularly ones where
and I think this is why they
specifically in 2007 when they went
after the Prosperity Gospel preachers
for you know for uh you know
specifically because they are obviously
using a lot of that money that
parishioners send them in apparently in
good faith to enrich themselves they
have massive Mansions they have flashy
cars they have private jets that they go
around the world in and all this other
kind of [__] so obviously they're not
using it just to like feed the hungry or
do Christian Outreach or anything like
that they're obviously using it to pay
for like I said gold-plated toilet seats
and [__] like that there's blow right
now right nobody needs that yeah
PTL Tammy Faye and and you know
The Bakers they had a [__] huge
compound that they live yeah as if it
was their house with big [__]
mansions and [__] they live well real
well
yeah you know
much more than a [__] say
Sports celebrity I mean you know they
were like [__] they made more money
than a sports team I think they made a
[__] ton of money yeah you could just
buy something they could just buy it
Tammy had a [__] ton of clothes and
shoes and [__] and [__]
I think [__] uh Baker had a bunch of
cars
I guess he didn't have as many girls as
he wanted he was evidently having to
drug some of them or one of them at
least I don't know how true that was but
that was the allegations
yeah that's she said that he yeah drug
drugged her and raped her yeah he said
it was consensual but I'm not really
buying that sorry
because of course he's gonna say that
it's hard to say
she was also involved in that church
well she worked for them yeah but that's
the same as being involved in that
church she was
I've also heard that she was like that's
what she did is that she got involved
with churches
and basically tried to sleep with
preachers and that's what that's kind of
what her job was she was a
my understanding was that she was a
what do they call them a
[__] grouping she was a church groupie
she tried to get into a bag of church
and [__] high-ranking dudes and
I mean she had the body for it
and that so it's probably it was
probably true about her
I think everybody at the level she was
at was what was a predator
you know I mean these are not these are
businesses man this is like corporate
businesses and everybody in this [__]
is a [__] predator of some sort they
know they know what's going on
they're just pretending that they don't
know I don't believe anything from these
people
well I for sure don't believe Jim Baker
I believe her more than I believe Jim
Baker that's for sure I think they're
equally unreliable you know that's what
I thought so I don't know like just he
really didn't seem like it and then
later on she's making porn and [__] nah
come on well like I said maybe she just
leveraged the [__] into I think she was
always like that well I don't well I
don't know I don't know her I mean you
know
I used to remember she used to go on the
Howard Stern Show all the time and
[__] Howard would
[__] with her and no I just got the I
got I got the based on her character uh
my take of her character is that she was
just another opportunist
yeah I mean possibly yeah all right so
um we're gonna be here all night if okay
yes we don't get on with this okay so um
I also wanted to mention Joel Osteen a
little bit um I kind of feel like his
biggest
um Scandal was maybe
after Hurricane Harvey in uh August of
2017 he was accused of not opening his
big uh mega church the Lakewood Church
uh you know after all the flooding and
stuff like to let people stay in there
and um because it used to be like a
sports arena 16 000 seats and they
basically when they got called out on it
they're like hey why don't you open up
this church you're supposed to be a
Christian you're supposed to be helping
people and all these people are
displaced because of the storm
and uh their excuse was oh well our [__]
flooded too except like then a bunch of
people took pictures and said yeah their
[__] didn't flood so they didn't open it
and then only after he got called out
like he came out and said oh uh it was
totally open I don't know why everybody
got the idea that it wasn't open and
then like he had to open it like a
couple days later but he only did that
after like everybody yelled at him about
it so there was that he kind of seems
like a
like a [__] too but you know what I
mean all these all these people kind of
yeah like they're all about the same
it's like cheese dicks to be honest with
you yeah
so uh so yeah so let's talk a little bit
about Jimmy Swaggart uh probably most
famous for [__] crying on TV after he
got uh caught but like I said not I
don't think he's crying because he was
sorry that he did the [__] he's just
sorry he got caught that up which I
think is yeah which I think is kind of
the case with a lot of these
[__]
and Jimmy Swagger like I said is
amazingly still alive I thought he would
have been dead by now
he was born in 1935 but nope uh he's
apparently still kicking so that's crazy
so he's actually from Louisiana and I
actually I feel like I had known this
factoid at some point and then totally
forgot about it until I was researching
the show again but he actually started
out more as I mean his dad was I guess
like a um was a preacher uh Pentecostal
and so he kind of grew up in that
environment but I had forgotten that
Jimmy Swaggart's cousin was Jerry Lee
Lewis I forgot that they were related
and Mickey Gilley like the country
singer he's also
um Jimmy Swaggart's cousin so I had
totally forgotten that there was that
whole uh link up which is [__] crazy
so Jimmy Swagger because he grew up like
in a very religious family and also like
a very musical family I guess he
originally started out as a gospel
singer and uh if you hear him play piano
because I guess he's he's even won
Grammys like for gospel music and that
was how he originally got famous did you
know that that Jimmy Swaggart was
related to Jerry Lee Lewis no I didn't
know they're cousins and Mickey Gilley
the country singer
I feel like I knew that a long time ago
and that I forgot but then I was like
looking it up again I was like oh yeah
that's right
um but yeah so so he started out as like
a gospel singer he plays piano if you
hear him play piano he plays very much
like Jerry Lee Lewis so you know what I
mean
um so he's uh he started preaching
though like in his parents Ministry
and became an evangelist in 1958 like I
said he was born in 1935. the [__] is
still alive that's amazing I guess maybe
God does love these [__]
because they live forever they look like
old [__] lizard people and they're
still kicking and they're like [__]
100 years old good drugs I guess I don't
know what the [__] their deal is
well it's probably all that money I'm
sure that money and they don't live a
hard lifestyle that's true
so yeah so he put out a bunch of gospel
albums as I mentioned in the 60s and
then he started doing like a radio show
that had music but also had him
preaching on it and it got like really
popular and his music was really popular
as well like he sold like a [__] ton of
records and his uh radio show started
getting really popular so he start went
to television and then he started doing
a television show in 1975 which
eventually went National
and uh I guess at its peak it was like
two million people were watching it
which was I guess was kind of a big deal
for televangelist back then
now Jimmy Swaggart
so he went on like televangelist do
however uh his first Scandal arose in
1986. now
this right here is because remember how
you were talking about how everybody
knows like they're they all know they're
up to like some [__] but they just like
keep it to themselves or whatever uh
Jimmy Swaggart didn't do that and I'm
just like this is really dumb because I
was like you know that whole you know
that whole phrase about people that live
in glass houses and shouldn't throw
stones blah blah
um he didn't take that advice because
the reason the the way that his first
Scandal got exposed
was he came out and accused his other
this other minister like this at the
Assemblies of God like the same place he
was at accused that guy named Marvin
Gorman of having a bunch of extramarital
Affairs and he just like was on TV like
talking about this [__] like
he's like immoral blah blah and I was
like maybe maybe
if you're also involved in some immoral
[__] quote unquote maybe you should keep
your [__] trap shut because they just
they can't help themselves no they can't
help them you're thinking like a sane
person well well thank you yeah I know
you're saying that like an insult no no
no you're thinking like a sane person
he's probably [__] cheating on a
bunch of women and he's going man my
competition is cheating on a bunch of
women too I'm gonna get him first okay
because this [__] is gonna get me all
right eventually he's going to turn on
me and tell everybody so I'm gonna get
him first and if he comes around with
accusations against me I'll just say now
he's making that up because I caught him
so it's a war between Liars that you
know it's not makes total sense in the
mind of a sociopath
I can think that way when I need to
I probably think that way naturally but
well I was just gonna say I think
probably because you are assisting yeah
I don't consider myself Associated bed I
don't know you kind of are you like it's
more like a high functioning psychopath
but yeah well okay tomato tomato I'm
just saying
but now he's gonna go nah I'm gonna get
that [__] before he gets me well that's
the thing so he did get that [__] like
he says about oh Marvin he's like
[__] around his wife like a multiple
times yeah I'm gonna take all his so
Gorman got uh defrocked yeah and um his
ministry like ended pretty much and uh
gorba was uh was Matt yeah so he
actually sued Jimmy Swaggart for
defamation uh and conspiracy to ruin his
reputation and he won uh he actually got
a 10 million settlement in 1991. uh
although I think he only ended up
getting 1.75 million yeah however
Swagger's lawyers probably told him how
it would all go [__] he probably had
this [__] planned out Minister yeah
he'll counter Sue and this and that and
you probably he'll win something you
only had ten percent of that you'll
probably end up having to pay him off
for a million that's probably what they
told him
they got all that [__] figured out
but uh because Marvin was mad and I
guess the lawsuit wasn't enough yeah so
he actually hired his son and his
son-in-law to go I guess he knew that
Swaggart was up to some [__]
so he sent the Son and the son-in-law
out to this uh airport in uh Metairie
New Orleans yeah
um to like hide out so they so they
rented a room and they put like a camera
with like a telephoto lens like in the
[__] window because I guess they knew
that a prostitute worked there and that
like a lot of dudes would like come in
and out so they were like filming the
room
so they filmed the room and uh they got
Jimmy Swagger on coming in tape like
going into the room and coming out they
got a bunch of other dudes as well
famous dudes are regular dudes I don't
know they just like I guess it was just
regular dudes yeah um but so I guess
it's just a regular old Street house
pretty much I mean Deborah Murphy was
her name okay
and so this is like it's so funny
because they're like so they're filming
Jimmy Swaggart going in to see a sex
worker and I guess to to make it so that
he couldn't leave right away like they
let the air out of his tires I'm like
are you guys 12 what the [__] this is
like this [__] it's like stupid got you
[__] I know so they yeah so they took
extensive like photos of him like coming
in and out of like going in and out of
this nerdiest church dudes out doing the
dude I know it's ridiculous
so then after that like I guess Marvin
he didn't make it public at first like
he actually went to Jimmy Swaggart first
and he said um you know I'll I guess
I'll I'll just like not release this
information to the public if you
publicly apologize to me and help get me
reinstated like as because he got
defrocked you know what I mean like from
his ministry
so um and then he said oh not only do
you have to apologize but you also have
to come out and say that you made it all
up like about the the Affairs that I had
which I don't know if he did have I'm
assuming he probably did
um because I don't trust you these
[__] they probably yelled at
horrible yeah they're all doing bad [__]
so Marvin actually uh sat on the
information for a year because he said
I'll give you a while to do it and blah
blah so he waited for a year and then he
wrote a note to Jimmy Swaggart and like
handed it to him saying hey your time's
up I'm gonna like tell the Press if you
don't you know do what I said and Jimmy
Swaggart wouldn't do it so basically
Marvin Gorman was like okay well I'm
gonna I'm gonna like pull the pull the
pin on that yeah and so yeah he went out
there and like I said they showed all
the proof and it's like look there's
this woman and she's you know a
prostitute she lives and they had all
these men and there's Jimmy Swagger
going in and out and the other thing
so um I can take that I can take that
blow don't worry about it I'll talk my
way out of it yeah yeah of course well
at first like okay so they brought him
in and I guess like they you know the
they have like a whole hierarchy for
this kind of crap so so they they
brought Jimmy Swaggart and they said
okay well
um they recommended that he should be
suspended suspended from broadcasting it
is for three months which doesn't really
seem like that long a time but whatever
so
um basically okay so what ended up
happening was that the woman Deborah
Murphy
Murphree like it's yeah M it's
m-u-r-p-h-r-e-e okay like it's a I've
seen it before but yeah yeah awesome
that's that's some [__] ass [__]
spelling right there that's some Cajun
[__] murfrey yeah that's your name yeah
um yeah but she basically said yeah was
she Redbone or white or white woman I
don't know okay I don't know I've never
seen a picture of her okay but um
probably a [__] juicy ass RedBone bro
I don't know yeah but she um yeah she
said that you know she'd engaged in
sexual acts with him she had posed nude
for him blah blah yeah now they gave her
a polygraph test interestingly and they
apparently she failed it
um but they kind of she kind of wrote
that off later saying well she was on
coke at the time or something like that
but um she basically like went on I
think she sold her story she was gonna
sell it to The Inquirer but after she
failed the um the polygraph test they
even The Inquirer wouldn't take it which
I was like wow that's uh they they at
least yeah I was like even they even
they have standards who knew but um
because I was like man they they could
have printed anything but um yeah well I
kind of feel like Swagger was at first
trying to take the attack that oh well
you know it was a setup but the thing
about it was that he admitted that he
did it later so it wasn't a setup but he
tried to make it seem like that because
I kind of feel like that's the go-to
that they always kind of say they what
they first deny it and then they're like
well here's a picture of you like
humping her um it's a setup
it's a it's a fake it's Photoshop you
know what I mean it's like they they
have to come up with something what are
they gonna do somebody [__] good it
would be nicer if they just say yeah I
did that [__] sorry somebody googled
this woman for me in the comments
section tell me what she looked like for
some reason like during my research I
never like it never occurred to me
what Murphree
I got Cajun cousins and [__] coming up
out of Mississippi I know the area
go down to [__] Slidell [__]
Metairie all the time my cousins live
right live right outside [__]
Metairie actually so I know where I know
what they're talking about yeah yeah but
yeah so like I said The Enquirer
we're gonna give her I think they're
gonna give her like 100 Grand but then
they like backed out on it when she
failed the polygraph yeah
um which like I said I didn't even know
the Inquirer had standards but okay I
learned something new today but uh but
then like well Penthouse bought it
though so so it went public anyway
so what ended up happening after that
very famously
in February of 1988
um Jimmy Swagger went on TV and he
didn't say exactly what it was that he
did
um but I mean I guess everybody knew at
this point because it had been reported
all over the media but he didn't mention
it and he came on and did it's very
famous It's All Over YouTube uh it's
called the I had sinned speech and he
just said it I'm just crying and crying
and like I said even the picture of his
face is all wet it's just like
absolutely the I have sinned against you
that [__] was a meme back in there it
was yeah before they were even before
there were memes
over and over and over again on TV I
mean it was it was parodied like so many
times like back in the 80s because it
was like
I mean it was just like so transparently
he's just up there [__] crying I was
like Jesus Christ putting on a show yeah
uh you know
he's asking that your precious blood
would wash and cleanse every stain yeah
even the [__] Stains yeah I guess so
those ones too that's that's important
so uh so yeah so I guess they decided
like the you know the Assemblies of God
peeps in Louisiana they initially
suspended Swaggart for three months but
then decided to go whole hog and do like
the when it went National they said no
we're gonna suspend him for two years
because apparently the national uh
whatever of the Assemblies of God they
have what they call their standard
two-year suspension for sexual
immorality I was like so this happens
often enough that you have a standard
two here suspension it's like okay so
yeah they did so they kicked him out for
uh for two years I guess now the thing
about it was that when they interviewed
Jimmy Swagger they didn't really think
that he was sorry like um and he didn't
really seem to be genuinely
repentant so they then they went ahead
and defrocked him uh and they took away
his ministerial license
so at that point uh Jimmy Swaggart went
Indy uh he became a non-denominational
Pentecostal Minister because like I said
he was specifically Assemblies of God
before but they kicked him out and it
wouldn't let him uh preach anymore at
least in their denomination so he had to
go like be an independent Pentecostal
Minister but uh you know don't cry for
him because he turned out okay uh he
actually started Jimmy Swaggart
Ministries and that's in Baton Rouge
Louisiana and he started the Sun Life
broadcasting network which is still on
Ben said that she looks like a uh since
she looked like a what a truck stop good
time girl a good A Truck Yeah she looks
like a lot of lizard she looks like a
lot lizard that's me
what was this picture of her like back
in the day like back in the 80s or now
yeah I don't know yeah it's got to be a
[__] gotta be an 80s pitcher gotta
see what [__] he was looking at at
the time
now had this just been one thing like I
said I don't begrudge people going to
sex workers like I said if everyone is
consenting adults
um you know and no one's screwing anyone
else over decriminalized yeah I I don't
have a problem with that at all people
can do what they want with their bodies
who gives a [__] yeah I'm just saying
it's like I said it's not I'm not so
much criticizing that I'm criticizing
the hypocrisy of him like preaching
against that kind of crap and then doing
yeah crap like I said you know if you're
gonna like tell other people not to do
it you better not be doing it
Christianity has some weird things
especially like Southern Baptist
Pentecost they have a very strange
interpretation of scripture okay and of
the times from which Christianity came
it clearly says
that a man
has a right to his wife
his wife's handmaidens and any other
servant that the wife has
okay so in other words
marriage isn't between a man and a woman
marriage is between a man a woman a
woman a woman a woman a woman a woman
and any other woman that a man wants
that's what real Christian marriage is
yeah you can tell men wrote that [__]
yeah of course
yeah it's between you your wife and all
her handmaidens and any other woman that
works for her
yeah they're all yeah Dominion got
dominion over all that which like I said
that's what you know still some sex of
the Mormons do that and all that kind of
and there was no there was no
stipulation that you can only have one
wife that's nowhere in there this is
something an imagination of modern
Christians
Charlemagne I think he had five six
wives you know and he was like the head
of the Holy Roman Empire you know which
that really didn't last that wasn't
reality but
really it wasn't up until just the
modern era that Christian men only had
one wife most of them had a bunch of
them and then um
the idea that you were married in a
church is modern
usually if you were living with a woman
you were married to her
you didn't need any kind it wasn't until
later they decided they could make money
off making you marry this woman you know
what I mean he had to do it in the
church
it's about money
but originally any woman you hung out
with too long you were married to
y'all have been hanging out to doing a
lot too much together y'all are married
yeah y'all got kids you're married yeah
that's you know fornicator yeah
yeah oh no
that's not what it meant I'm just making
a joke yeah okay all right
if you were just around a woman for a
long time you were married
so uh speaking of being around a woman
for a long time
not really I'm just I was trying to do a
Segway but uh but yeah so like I said he
went independent started his own network
and stuff like that so you know like I
said he was fine but then because
dude just can't learn
only a little while later in October of
uh he got pulled over by the cops for
driving on the wrong side of the road
which I don't know where the [__] he was
doing that and in the passenger seat of
the car was yet another sex worker
Rosemary Garcia
uh she said that Jimmy Swaggart she'd
been on the side of the road you know
applying her trade and Jimmy Swaggart
stopped the car and uh proposed sex to
her so he'll pick up Street Walkers yeah
damn
and she told the Press she said he asked
me for sex I mean that's why he stopped
me that's what I do I'm a prostitute and
I was like I like this girl around but I
like her fourth right now I just like I
just think it's funny that this guy with
all this money is just going for Street
Walkers he's not even he's got well [__]
those well that's his Kink guy that's
his Kink yeah he's talking about Kink
yeah that's that's definitely he's not
even going for the [__] call girls
you know what I mean because like it's a
safer well he likes danger this dude
likes Dave that's what I'm saying
because a dude like that could afford
not only I don't want to say like a
higher class but but something that was
more discreet is what I'm saying yeah
like you could do it where you didn't
get caught you're cruising down the
street on the wrong side of the [__]
road and just picking up sex workers
that are just on the side of the street
yeah and he's not going first I mean a
thousand dollar high-class call girl
who's not just totally run through you
know what I mean [__] she's going
he's going from bottom of the barrel
like totally just run through you know
publish like I said maybe that must
maybe that was his cake It's gotta be
judging you've got money
and and you're you're hard up like that
you need the help of a professional
you're not going to go for a [__]
Street girl you're gonna go for a real
Pro you know who's
she lives off the backs of a couple of
whales you know what I mean maybe she's
got 10 15 clients the regular ones she
might only have four clients that are
[__] just
Dubai level [__] whales you know so
she's not busted out you know she's
probably screwing less dudes than your
average chick at the club you know so
he could afford that so this tells me
that this is cake yeah he likes it well
that's the that's what he likes a bad
girl yeah maybe on some level he wanted
to get caught why would you if you if
you had a sex worker in your car why
would you be driving on the wrong side
of the road for one thing
because he's Breaking All the Rules
that's what I mean
[__] [__] it I'm gonna drive on the
other side of the road with my hoe yeah
yeah yeah do something to me [__]
yeah he's being God's on my side he's
being gangster I guess yeah God's
gangster
Ben said some of those evangelists had
to be careful about how they paid for
sex Services they were paranoid about
their hotel bills or sex service charges
being made public yeah I mean and I
could see that like if you didn't want
that getting out but there's ways to get
around no
that they could have [__] contacted
in Vegas
that could have given them clean women
that were just untraceable like I said
there's no way there's ways to get
around that because not just evangelists
anybody that doesn't want to get caught
with that kind of thing with its
politicians or whatever the [__] there's
ways to get around that situation the
fact that Jimmy Swaggart
did that like just picked up a woman on
the side of the road and then was
driving down the wrong side of the road
and then got pulled over by the cops
um that says it just seemed like he
wanted to get caught I'm just saying
uh Oracle said I have to wonder if he
felt he was under Divine production
maybe I said either he really wanted to
get caught or he just thought he was so
awesome that
he could just do whatever well and the
thing about it too was that this time so
like the first time he gets caught with
like a prostitute at first he tries to
like deny it and everything but then
he's like yeah I did that [__] and then
like he on TV crying about it like oh
everybody feel bad for me and Jesus
forgive me and blah blah and all that
other [__] but then the second time
which was only a couple of years later
like he goes in front of his
congregation and basically says it's
none of you guys's damn business
basically which like I said it wouldn't
be if you I mean it wouldn't be
anybody's business if your whole like
shtick and your whole like uh you know
the way that you make money is by
telling other people what to do and
claiming to be righteous and everything
like that like it wouldn't be anybody's
business but you're making it everyone's
business by doing that
so yeah so basically said um the Lord
told me instead of your business that's
what he told the [__] congregation
so um so basically after that uh even
though so I guess like a lot of his
congregation a lot of whoever was
running this [__] like we're happy about
it you know not good Optics
so uh essentially
um the Jimmy Swaggart's son he had a son
named Donnie
and uh he's like yeah Dad's gonna be
stepping down for a little while
um he's gotta go like get some
counseling and [__] like that so yeah
that's what he did so uh so Donnie took
the [__] over but as I mentioned Jimmy
Swaggart is still alive and he is
currently a senior pastor at the Family
Worship Center in Baton Rouge Louisiana
that he founded
and uh they still have that Family
Worship Center they still have uh he
still does a telecast they still have
radio and TV shows uh several of them on
the Sun Life radio network they still
have that they still have a satellite TV
network
all of that uh his wife Francis also has
a show called Francis and friends they
do like Bible study programs all that
kind of [__]
um mostly it seems like the sun is
running it now but Jimmy Swaggart is
still around which kills me but I was
just like you weren't here for the
second thing but like the second time
when he got caught with the second
prostitute he basically told the
congregation Jesus said instead of your
business
that's awesome I didn't know why I
should at least should have played that
from the very beginning Jesus said it's
none of your business between me and
Jesus me and this is me and my sins okay
which like I said it wouldn't be
anybody's business if you didn't make if
you didn't like let's drop in your nuts
and you're on the congregation let me
drop the nuts on the congregation
I do what I want I do what I want he's
like pookie I say that all the time too
well that's what we say in regards to
Pookie because Pookie definitely is I do
what I want yeah
but yeah
Jimmy Swagger does what he wants to and
obviously like
these that's another thing that kind of
pisses me off about these people is that
as much as like I said you know Jim
Baker did it Jimmy Swaggart did it it's
like as much as they get caught doing
nefarious [__] and then like they piss
and moan and cry about it and how
persecuted they are and then but then
like years later they're still
Millionaires and they're still on TV and
stuff I'm like oh boohoo Oracle in there
is commenting you know what what is this
is this Divine inner is this Divine
protection if he felt like he was under
Divine yeah or is this a protected does
this speak to a self-destructive
industry yeah okay it might be a little
bit of both honestly maybe but
Oracle as a man I'm gonna say that what
it was is it was more along the lines of
just ego
he was feeling good about himself that
he could get away with anything
all right that uh you gotta watch people
like that yeah
I don't think it had anything to do with
God per se I don't really think that
these guys are actually religious I
think they're [__] psychos
and I think he was just like I do I can
do whatever I want I run this
[__] that's what he's thinking
at the time I can pick up these [__]
bent ass busted out hoes and and screw
them and no one will know I can drive on
the other side of the road and no one
will know I'm unaccountable yeah yeah
I'm unaccountable nobody can make me pay
for anything
I think that's what he's doing well and
the thing about it is it's probably
because he's normally pretty restricted
inside this little [__] shell of the
church and he's getting sick of that
[__] and when nobody's watching he
[__] acts a fool
well and I was gonna say too is that
they you can't really like uh blame them
for thinking that because like in a lot
of ways particularly in the 80s and
stuff is that yeah there would be a big
Scandal and there'd be free money but
then like they would usually land on
their feet and it's like oh well [__] I
can just do all kinds of bad [__] and
it's like yeah I just gotta go on TV and
cry and say how sorry I am but then I
can just go back to raking in like all
these Rubes will still send me money
yeah probably so [__] with your mind
yeah because like yeah they might get to
a point where it's like I can do
whatever the [__] I want it's like this
isn't gonna go away and uh they probably
have little fits and [__]
and then they have to act a certain way
around everybody else when they're at
the church land where they're working in
this business you know what I mean and
they have to act holier than now and
that becomes a burden these are the kind
of dudes that if they could get away
with it would hire a dominatrix to make
them drink out of the toilet and make
them take it up the ass they're that
kind of guy
free me from this power I have yeah you
know that kind of [__] you know yeah
we've said that before yeah I am so
powerful degrade me I've heard that's a
very common Kink for people that are not
just televangelists but people who are
like it has a lot of power CEOs anybody
that has like a lot of power in their
normal life or a lot of time treat me
like [__] yeah they want to be treated
like yeah a dog essentially they want to
like drink out of the toilet and like
wear a dog collar and they want to like
have somebody step on their testicles or
some chick to [__] Peg them yeah yeah
honestly I kind of enjoy those testicle
stepping on videos Jenny [__] is into
that [__] weirdness I just it's
Andrea and [__] trying to Peg
[__] and [__] like that man
there's Wiki to have escaped my
virginity around this [__] one we got
we got into a whole thing like one time
where we got into like this wait wait at
this Rabbit Hole of like all of this
um I just what's the name I know there's
a name for it because there's a name for
everything but the one where it's like
women in high heels like stepping on
dudes nuts yeah and it's just like every
time we would watch one I would just
cackle and cackle yeah and my [__] my
nuts would be jumping up I know it's
always like getting really uncomfortable
it's like funnier than that
I'm like what kind of sad sack has to go
through that [__] together I remember
the one where they had built this like
construction thing where he want to like
put his balls like up in a hole like
yeah and then she would like and I was
like I was like wow there's a lot of
thought put into this whoa whoa and then
there was and I was just laughing there
was one where this chicken is [__]
super [__] high-heeled platforms it's
just taking a running [__] start just
running towards this dude and doing a
running kick right in this [__] nuts
boom
[Music]
I'm like you said sad [__] you
put yourself up there for that [__]
well you know takes all kinds yeah I
mean you know some people are into it
like I said it's it's funny to me anyway
it's not particularly hot but I think
it's like really funny she's sadistic I
am a little bit
I don't know why that makes you laugh so
hard but it's like I just never I I
don't know I just feel like something
about that is very funny to me yeah I
just think it's okay
I just I just feel pitiful for these
[__] maybe that's why it's
funny what the [__] I don't know like I
said I don't judge other people's weird
kicks like a lot of people have
hurricanes but you know what it takes to
get you off man what the [__] is wrong
with you
that's gotta hurt I gotta I feel like I
mean you know I wouldn't want anybody
like you know kicking me in the couch or
anything like that and I'm sure that
doesn't hurt nearly as much
but
you know I'm just saying
Oracle said as a preacher's kid I view
televangelists with an extra skeptical
eye my dad didn't like them to put it
mildly uh but then Dad didn't get
ordained to get rich he wanted to help
people yeah I kind of feel like that's
that's kind of the shitty thing is that
you know I'm not saying that some of
these like some people that get that are
ministers and things like that like they
do genuinely believe and they do
genuinely want to help people and that's
why they get into it but those are not
the the ones that get rich so yeah no
you're not gonna get rich being a good
person yeah and and that's like one of
the shitty things about the world it's
like usually like the worst people yeah
the closer you are because it's [__]
a total psychopath the Richer well
because it's easier to make money if you
don't care about who you step on oh yeah
who you [__] if you don't have a
conscience you must annihilate the
competition and some of the competition
is internal and it's your friends you do
they just [__] people over
and
they do [__] that ends up [__] making
tens of thousands sometimes millions of
people unemployed and they still do it
they would like well somebody else would
do it you know what I mean yeah it might
as well be me pulling the trigger on
this because
anybody else would pull the trigger on
it it would just be somebody else that's
another thing that's the thing well that
that's another thing that I've noticed
about people like that yeah um is that
they're terrible so they assume everyone
else is terrible as well like they don't
seem to be able to Fathom that other
people wouldn't do the same things that
they do like they think at that level
though I think at that level it is well
at that level but I'm just saying in
general like I don't think they they
don't seem to be able to Fathom that
everyone in the world is not as terrible
hoarding over that look at her lording
over that horde of [__] toys
pile of toys and she's sitting over
there looking at like the dragon out of
[__] small in the dragon yeah those
are your toys yeah she's over there like
sitting on the piles for all my babies
so they got the pile of babies like all
the little toys stuffed animal toys yeah
all right so let's talk about we want to
talk about Jim and Tammy Faye and then I
want to talk about Ted Haggard okay yeah
we're gonna go I'm gonna go ahead and
defend Tammy a little bit well I already
did she seemed like an okay person like
I said she got caught up she wasn't a
fantastic person because like I said I'm
pretty sure she knew about it and hooked
up with this dude
she seemed like and okay and she's still
like a decent person deep down
um she had issues but a lot of people
have issues she needed to get laid by by
a good man that was part of it she
didn't have a good man but he did give
her a bunch of money and make her rich
but that's not really the same thing
though I mean that's not really it's as
fulfilling yeah she was not fulfilled
yeah and I kind of feel like I haven't
read her she's wrote a couple memories
like before she died but um she and they
kind of went into this in the movie A
little bit too but she always just felt
very um lonely yeah and it wasn't just
because Jim was always like [__]
around on her it was that he was like so
wrapped up once they started making
money he got so wrapped up in
constantly like making money and
building new [__] and everything like
that he was like never home and he never
paid her any attention and stuff like
that so she and she had to she was kind
of stuck in this palatial Mansion like
raising the kids by herself and he
didn't like he was never around you know
what I mean and she didn't like that I'm
pretty sure he was more gay than
straight
maybe like I said there were there were
a lot they didn't really go into it a
lot I think that like they brought it up
it's been brought up a few times that he
had relations with you know men and
women
but they don't really go on as much
about that as they do about like Ted
Haggard but I mean we'll get into that
in a little bit too but I I don't know I
don't know why that is
but so yeah so Jim and Tammy Faye and if
you haven't say if you have HBO Max I
mentioned this earlier
um that movie on there from 2021 the
eyes of Tammy Faye which is kind of
loosely based on the documentary they
made back in 2000 which was called the
same thing
um is actually really good like we
watched it last night and it was like
yeah good movie it was pretty
entertaining like the acting is really
good it was kind of a blast from the
past because they would show like old
clips from television programs from the
PTL at that time and they would
superimpose the new actor and the new
actress in there yeah and I kind of
remember that era right and the symbols
that they had with the globe and
everything in the world PTL globe and
[__] praise the Lord yeah it was so
funny how crude all that stuff looks by
today's standards how bad the technology
was in the 80s I like that in the movie
they really did try to like replicate
that shitty looking shot on video shitty
shot on video [__] terrible
superimposers and stuff yeah I mean they
did a good job
but yeah so yeah um so Tammy Faye was
actually from uh Minnesota
and because you were saying like while
we were watching the movies like why is
she talking like that I said because
she's yeah Minnesota why is she talking
like like a Yankee I thought she was
Southern she goes no man yeah she's from
Minnesota and Jim Baker is from uh
Michigan okay
but they actually assumed that they were
Southern now
why because because of how they look in
there because of how they look and how
they talked and yeah and the PTL and
[__] that's a that would that was went
over real well in the South so I just I
yeah
they're Midwestern but um
I kind of feel like after I don't
remember if this was at the same time as
Tammy Faye or after Tammy Faye if she
was like a trendsetter or whatever but I
do kind of feel like in in the
Evangelist World there was kind of a
little bit of a Mini Boom lit in crazy
looking women like women with like big
[__] huge hair helmets and like crazy
[__] clown makeup and [__] like that
Tammy thought she was Betty Boop
I believe they kind of went into that
yeah
um
the famous images of [__] Tammy was a
little short
kind of woman chubby with a big round
chubby face big cheeks and these
ridiculous [__] hot eye makeup just
ridiculous eye makeup huge false
eyelashes and [__]
come to think of it yeah that's Betty
Boop is what she's talking about but it
was 80s color colorized Betty Boop
the thing is is that she was actually
that's how she ended up she was actually
very cute she was a cute little chick
yeah we Googled some pictures apparently
she's really really cute yeah when she's
really young she was a good person she
just got caught up in this [__] really
got caught up with the wrong guy
yeah I think you know it'd be good it
does kind of seem yeah yeah like I said
I don't want to excuse her completely
because she's not completely I don't
think she well the money was racking in
she's just going right she's just going
along how could she stop it [__] you
know her husband wouldn't let her stop
that [__] and she kind of rebelled
against him with the gay stuff yeah yeah
she did that like without his yeah she
did a lot of because like I said she
seemed like a genuinely good person who
really did genuinely love people like
she really did like people and you know
Jim was at least bisexual so her coming
out with the AIDS thing and
helping gay people it was in a way kind
of like supporting Jim Jim was gay he
had been he would have been considered
LGBT by today's standards
he wouldn't have wanted it to be seen
that way but that's what he was he was
closet he was in the closet
see like I said I'm just I really wish
like I said I don't think she cared
about him yeah
yeah she did I think she loved him so
and I'm not sure it was really returned
I think he thought she was annoying
I think it seemed like At first like I
think he was into her at first when she
was young and pretty but I think yeah I
think after a while like she started
having kids and stuff I mean it happens
a lot I guess and like I guess he's
you know she started to get on his nerve
she was a little bit
outspoken
um you know she was very forthright and
very friendly and she didn't really care
about
convention particularly like religious
convention and there is actually like a
very funny scene in the movie where
they're having this big meeting at
um I guess it was falwell's house wasn't
it falls and uh Vincent D'Onofrio plays
uh Jerry Falwell in the movie he's only
in it for like a few minutes but he's
[__] great
so um so they had that and she just like
invites she just like she was supposed
to unspoken like go sit with the women
and talk about women stuff yeah but she
didn't want to do that and so she just
dragged a chair over and sat at the
table with all the men and started like
kind of debating with him and stuff and
all the dudes were like getting super
uncomfortable and kind of like hey Jim
like rain in your wife or whatever so
we're the priest class but she wasn't
but she wasn't aware of it because she
was just kind of like being the way she
was you know what I mean well like I
said before
when I was when this was all going down
this PTL was the one I remembered the
most yeah it's the one that stood out
the most
and I had a Christian background of
course coming up out of a Christian
Military Academy in Christian relatives
and I'd been to church well not
regularly but I did I I knew the basics
PTL was the least Christian of them it
was not that religious it was more like
a variety show that had a generic
Christian veneer over it
it was more like entertainment than
anything to entertainment for Christians
more than a
preacher show I don't remember any
preaching happening in it it was just a
bunch of guests I'd put it up there with
like Ricky Lake
or you know what I mean or [__] well
Jim Baker's original idea for it was
essentially he wanted like a late show
like The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson
except for religious people yeah that's
that's so like a variety show like
they'd have they'd have Christian bands
on or like musicians they'd have like
interviews with celebrities like talking
about they would talk about jesusy stuff
but some of the stuff they did was like
not yeah you know they would just do
little cooking segments and stuff like
like a t like the Today Show or yeah
like I said like a lady I would catch it
after work sometimes or late at night
when everything else was off
because you know television would go off
people don't realize that nowadays but
television would go off at around 11 and
after that then they'd show reruns
they'd have Ricky Lake and [__] like
that on it or the [__] that from the
daytime television shows I remember that
this was on one of the channels
and sometimes I'd watch it for a little
bit it was watchable it was watchable I
would goof on it a little bit but it was
watchable
um
but
this one struck me as the least
religious
yeah it was just Christian Motif really
Oracle said Tammy was better than the
average televangelist because she was
nice to an AIDS patient when so many
others shun didn't scorned them yeah
particularly in the 80s like I said we
were talking about that earlier
um so if there was any Divine Justice in
this world Jim Baker would have got
cancer instead of her right and it's
like I I know it's uncharitable to think
that but I was just like why are all
these old horrible reptilian
[__] still alive and Tammy Faye
like to seemed like the only decent one
among them is dead Tammy was nice that's
what I mean she seemed like a nice
person yeah like she was kind of
ridiculous oh yeah yeah she was
ridiculous she's getting high on [__]
medication and [__] but well they gave
her Ativan yeah and she got addicted to
it she had to go to Betty Ford yeah it
was the whole thing but like I said I
kind of I kind of feel bad for her
though like you know I'm not saying she
was a fantastic out of all those out of
all of that out of all the [__] these
lizard people and they were lizard
people I know the other definitions like
the AJ version of lizard people or
whatever
yeah these are still lizard people okay
out of all of them you could kind of
probably hang out with Tammy yeah
okay she was funny yeah she seemed okay
yeah
she probably would have been a hoot yeah
to hang out with
so this is like some [__] that you'd
bring her to a [__] fetish show and
she would try to rationalize that the
next thing you know you'd have her in
PVC and stuff
yeah she seemed like she probably get it
she'd get into that yeah she's like
we're gonna make you a dominatrist and
she's like oh yeah I could do that I'll
be done
yeah she tried to turn that [__] around
yeah
so uh so yeah so these two actually uh
met in 1960 they were both students at
the north central Bible College that's
in Minneapolis
and apparently according to Tammy at
least Jim basically asked her to marry
him like on their first date so love at
first sight I guess she was cute though
yeah yeah like I said we
will like pictures of her yeah because I
kind of feel like you say Tammy Faye
well she was Tammy fate Master right
because she married again like before
she died but like um which yeah I'll get
into that in a minute too how tall was
she do you think five five feet maybe I
don't know okay
um I forgot what I was going with that
okay so anyway
um
so this so they got married like not too
long after meeting each other
and then a year later they both dropped
out of college because they both wanted
to be they essentially wanted to start a
Ministry they wanted to travel around
the country and do I feel like
essentially they wanted to do tent
revivals you know what I mean where they
would go because she would sing and play
the accordion and stuff and then he
would preach so that was kind of what
they what they wanted to do
and uh they were also Assemblies of God
just like uh Jimmy Swaggart so yeah so
they would travel around in a car and go
to wherever would have them
and uh they also started a puppet show
which was you know for kids you know
with their puppets talking about Jesus
and whatnot
and I guess they had been doing that for
a little while and their puppet show
came to the attention of Pat Robertson
who we mentioned earlier who owned CBN
the Christian Broadcasting Network and
he thought that the puppet show was a
good idea so he said well hey I'll put
it on my channel you know what I mean on
my TV show
now um so Jim was like okay well if the
puppet show which I think was originally
just called Jim and Tammy or the Jim and
Tammy show or something like that
um they said if that does well then can
I do a show like I said he wanted to do
like something like the Johnny Carson
like The Tonight Show but but religious
with a religious angle so
um obviously the puppet show was very
successful
um so basically they said okay then
we'll let you do this
this kind of show that you're doing so
they started doing that the 700 Club and
that was obviously very successful
so Jim and Tammy uh started getting
famous like pretty quickly and uh again
like you know Tammy started having kids
they had a daughter whose name was also
Tammy they called her [__] though and
then they also had a son whose name was
Jay Charles and then they moved to
Charlotte North Carolina and that's
where Jim founded uh PTL the satellite
Network that was in 1974 which I guess
he was one of the first to start that
whole satellite thing they kind of
portrayed in the movie of him talking to
uh he was talking to Jerry Falwell right
yeah and Jerry fall was like yeah we got
two million people like watching our TV
show and Jim and Jim Baker is like yeah
we have a satellite Network and we got
like 40. we got like 40 million people
watching our share 200 or something like
ridiculous yeah because of the satellite
it's like it was a satellite it's
floating around up there on Earth
because yeah it didn't know what
satellites were back then I guess but
yeah so um so I guess I don't think he
was like the first one to do that but he
was definitely one of the um innovators
I guess or Pioneers in that regard yeah
I don't know if it was his satellite or
if he was just piggy paying the
piggyback on it
was never really clear huh did they
launch their own satellite I doubt it
they must have been renting oh that's
the thing I kind of feel like back then
you might have had to because it's not
like nowadays when there's like 40
bajillion satellites up there and you
can just ping [__] off whatever but it's
like maybe there was a satellite up
there that you could rent space on I
don't know maybe yeah I don't know how
it works back in the 70s I was just a
little kid then Julianne said Tammy was
411 and Jim was only five foot four holy
[__] I didn't realize he was that short
yeah that's shorter than me that's only
an inch taller than I am yeah because
I'm I'm only five four eleven I could
tell she was a small statured woman yeah
um which is unforgiving for weight
um but she was cute very cute if you
look at old pictures of her you can
Google them
she was much cuter without all that
makeup
yeah but after a while she didn't really
have a choice because she got everything
tattooed on well she didn't get all of
it tattooed on like she got lip liner
tattooed on okay she got eyeliner
tattooed on and she got eyebrow pencil
tattooed on okay but I'm pretty sure she
would always put on like the lashes okay
and the ridiculous
the ridiculous eye shadow yeah which is
like white it's like Frosty blue with
like white up here like but yeah she
committed to a certain look that was
frozen in time well and then I kind of
feel like she was pretty self-aware
because after a while everyone
Associated her with that look and she's
like well I can't change it now because
that's like her brand yeah because you
know she would have like she would have
these lashes on all this mascara and
then she would cry on TV and like
mascara be running on her face she's
like that's almost like her trademark
now so she can't like go back on it yeah
and it's definitely Betty Boop is what
is what I never thought about it but
yeah when they brought it up in the
movie I was like oh yeah okay
yeah and he even like and he even like
disparagingly said something they were
making fun of her of her voice yeah Jim
and his boyfriend were making fun of her
behind her back she overheard it in the
movie individually probably was based in
real life she probably knew that they
were making fun of her which uh
evidently devastated her so well I mean
that'd be pretty shitty like I'd be I'd
be pretty mad if I like came in a
[__] room and you were talking to
some of your Bros or something like that
or your boy yeah my boyfriend and you
were like saying some shitty stuff about
me like yeah look at her stupid hair and
her stupid whatever yeah her stupid yeah
I don't know my stupid whatever I'm
stupid everything so I don't really know
my stupid laugh my stupid butt I don't
know
anything no so I can I can understand I
felt you know whatever I feel sorry for
Tammy I did too you know I always liked
her I always liked her I always thought
she was interesting she was funny yeah
well a lot of people not do this yeah
well like I said I think the reason that
she appealed to people yeah she was
ridiculous and she looked ridiculous and
it was like easy to like make fun of her
because she was like a caricature of a
person
but I think deep down people responded
to
her seeming like to genuinely care about
people she did seem to genuinely care
about people I think she did I think she
was a good person yeah she seemed like a
good person and I think people were
responding to that yeah
in a way that they might not have like
now this was a time when
this is the time of television cable
television early cable television
there weren't that many channels and
there weren't that many shows if a woman
like this were to appear today in the
age of the internet and YouTube she
would have been lost and you never would
have known who this was right
it was just she was a person of the time
well that's why I didn't realize that a
lot of these [__] were still on
because it's like it's everything's so
diffused nowadays yeah like you know
scattered that you know they could have
a whole [__] Billion Dollar Empire
and I wouldn't know jack [__] about it
because I'm not like in that Circle back
in our day and some of y'all are you
couldn't escape it because everywhere
you couldn't escape it there was only so
many channels you knew everything that
was going on right
now it's like now it's impossible that's
impossible to keep track of everything
it's like it's got because like I said
there's so much stuff out there that
it's like everyone's just in their own
want to keep track of all of it well you
can I mean even if you wanted to like I
said I can't even keep track of like
[__] I like that I want to see like TV
shows movies books whatever like music
like stuff that's going I can't even
keep track of that like much less all
the other [__] tomorrow we're seeing
zymox that's right we got on the guest
list to see zymox for free and The
Starry Night is also opening aren't they
no I don't know I thought they were on
the same no they're no they're not
opening okay they're um who's opening
for them no I can't remember
Rose Garden Funeral party oh [__] man
okay I did the poster but it was a long
time ago I don't remember where is it
it's at the Abbey you know how to get
there downtown Orlando well okay okay I
have a GPS downtown Orlando yeah so yeah
tomorrow
downtown yeah it's in that area okay you
know what I mean like I said I have GPS
we'll figure it out I've never actually
been it'll be a Thursday so parking
shouldn't be a problem yeah it'll be all
right yeah it'll be all right and I
don't think it'll show that late I think
the doors are at seven okay we need to
get down there but I mean I don't get
home till six and then I'll have to come
home and get ready real quick fly
together but I think there's two opening
bands I have to look up again but I want
to be there through the whole show and
in the after show we've been we've been
invited to so I want to go there well
the aftershave the after party is at
Will's Pub oh yeah we can go to that
I'll go to that that starts at 11. okay
but like I said I gotta work on Friday
so we won't stay long don't don't stay
excited because I gotta get up at five
in the morning
uh but yeah
so
what they discovered was that so when
they did the PTL Club
um you know obviously very very
successful and again preaching
Prosperity Gospel and they were very
open about their wealth and they're just
kind of like I don't know like low-key
encouraging people it's like hey give us
money and you know this you'll end up
like us like all of these blessings that
we got are bloody blah
so essentially it's kind of like
um and then when Tammy Faye would come
on and she would like
uh you know be very open about various
things or would cry about something or
seem like I said I think people really
responded to that because usually when
she would come on and talk and stuff
like that they would make more money
like people would call in and pledge
more
so
um it was we were watching the movie
last night I don't remember if this
really happened or not because I wasn't
like a regular viewer of the PTL Club
but at one point because like I said um
Tammy Faye had a problem later on uh
with with an addiction to um Ativan
and so there was one time when they were
doing a show and I guess it was like a
fake uh like a Beach ocean kind of thing
in the background and so Chip Baker was
talking and she was like standing there
and then she was like hot as [__] and
then she started like she just kind of
like wandered off and then she's like
touching the background like oh it's
fake and then she like laid down on the
fake say it and stuff and I was like man
I have to look and see if that really
happened because that'd be [__]
hilarious a poor that poor lady she was
just she didn't know what the [__] was
going on there she was like so [__]
high but yeah so um
so yeah now while all this stuff while
they were getting super successful like
I said I kind of feel like everyone knew
who they were at this point like in the
1980s
but apparently behind the scenes at
least according to Tammy Faye's later uh
Memoirs
um you know [__] wasn't going so well
like in their marriage you know what I
mean um as I mentioned earlier Tammy
complained that Jim got to a point where
even though it seemed like at least
according to her
he seemed like he had really been you
know gung-ho about this whole Ministry
they were doing like at first but then
like the Richer they got and the more
famous they got the more consumed he got
with that end of it like everything was
just how can we make money off this and
how much everything was like cha-ching
you know what I mean and he didn't
really care about anything other than
that and he was always gone because they
really wanted to
you know they were building up the PTL
Network more they were like uh making
the studios bigger they're building new
Office Buildings they were building new
houses they were building they built
this whole compound called Heritage
Village and they also were talking about
doing like a theme park which I think
they did eventually build
um you know with Christian theme park
and where the [__] is it at it's in
North I want to say it's in North
Carolina but I can't remember
um but yeah yeah it's South Carolina
it's in South Carolina sorry
so so yeah so he was kind of like had
all these ideas and all these money
making schemes and I feel like she kind
of felt like she was neglected like I
said so she was constantly like at home
and she was taking care of the babies
and he was always gone and so she wasn't
really about it now I don't know if this
really happened in real life or what the
thing was but in the movie they showed
that
um she kind of had a little bit I don't
really know what the extent of the
relationship was but there was like a
little bit of a thing where she got into
a little bit of a fling with this guy
that was like a sound engineer I guess a
producer or a music producer like from
Nashville who came there to like record
her socks because she sang and stuff so
he was recording some um
an album for her it was definitely true
because she confessed to it yeah
I was like I said I was looking for it
and I didn't really see that much about
it but I didn't have like a lot of time
to look it up yeah but um but they
showed it in the movie and it's like I
guess he was like kind of into her
and she was pregnant at the time and
there was a funny scene in the movie
where she was uh
sitting on his lap we're not entirely
sure like what what the dictionary what
the dick situation was at that point in
time look like a cowgirl type situation
right but then her water broke yeah and
then he had to end up taking her to the
hospital and then Jim got mad because I
guess she had the baby like and Jim
wasn't there because he was too busy
[__] around doing something else with
some dudes what probably yeah and um or
other women or or both who knows I don't
know what he was up to but then he got
like mad at her because he's like oh
she's [__] around with that but she
was like you know you're never here and
it's like
you know he thought it was beautiful and
all this other kind of stuff he was her
friend right and I don't blame her I
don't to be honest I don't either um you
know she was neglected I mean [__]
around your spouse is not good but I'm
just saying in that case I'll give it
I'm gonna [__] say this [__]
man-to-man even though the audience
isn't a man it's got women in it too
no all right
Jim had all kinds of [__] money he
already had
children with this woman
they're living a palatial lifestyle
he's heading men and women
Jim okay
he's not gonna let his wife have a
boyfriend
see that's what made me mad it's like he
had probably already been [__] around
on her first already kind of lost
allegedly in her you know what I mean he
leaves her alone all the time and she's
stuck like raising these babies I don't
understand and [__] like that and then
like she kind of finds a friend and
maybe [__] around yeah and then he gets
mad
at her even though he's been doing the
same [__] yeah I mean I'm not I don't
like that I'm not one of these like cut
type [__] but I'm just saying
you have to be realistic if you are in a
marriage with this woman she's brought
you children you have all this [__]
prosperity
you've got a girlfriend
and in this case Jim's bisexual he's got
boyfriends too
you're not gonna let your wife have her
friend I don't really understand that
like I said I don't have a problem with
that situation as long as everyone is on
the same page yeah and as long as
everyone's allowed to do the same [__]
like you're not allowed to have a double
standard about that you're just not the
only thing as a man only thing I'd be
concerned about is I'd had to lay lay
down a rule like don't have his children
that would be the only which like I said
that's reasonable if everybody agrees to
that like I said as long as everybody's
on the same page
I just do what you want it's fine right
the only thing the only thing I don't
like about that kind of stuff is like
the secrecy yeah you know the Betrayal
but it's like and the double standard
like I said if you're out there [__]
around on your way for example yeah and
you're pretend like you're not and then
she go and then pretend you're not and
then she goes and [__] around because
she suspects you're [__] around her
she's lonely or whatever and then you
get mad at her about that oh no yeah and
then you've got a boyfriend away that
don't fly
he sent the boyfriend away yeah he made
you have to go back to Nashville which
that didn't make sense to me
at all because if I was Jim I would be
like well she's happy with this dude and
that it gets her off my back I'm kind of
sick of her she needs to have a
companion no I'm gonna hire you on for
another five-year contract I mean that's
it that would be that would be the last
thing that I can think you know what I
mean because Jim was apparently wasn't
sleeping with her no
according to it according to her right
according to her he wasn't he hadn't hit
in a long time
so what the [__] did he care what the
[__] did he care I cannot because it's
an ownership thing yeah
the only thing I could think of from
Jim's point of view is well if she gets
pregnant as his kid then then it's gonna
look funny
I would think legit part of the
agreement Jim say look look do what you
want have fun
just don't get pregnant by that dude
yeah like yeah and chances are what you
should be doing that anyway really and
chances are Tammy wouldn't wouldn't have
been interested in having to do his
children anyway I mean she already has
she already had children right and I'm
sure she probably didn't know anymore
but that's the thing it's like yeah that
that kind of made us mad like we were
watching yeah I don't get that like I
said and he was probably [__] around
at that point too they had so much money
and then they were business partners so
what what the [__] you know yeah it's
like quit your whining yeah
I don't I see I that is one of the
things that pissed me off the most is
one of these rules for me and not for
yeah rules for the end not for me
[__] I don't know yeah I don't
like it and they were both living large
so right nobody was stuck out
yeah other than her she couldn't have a
boyfriend right which is dumb yeah but
you know what I mean under those
circumstances no she should have been
able to like I said I you know
even if she'd have asked right before
she did it it's like hey you're never
here yeah I need to have a companion
like you know can I yeah you know you're
probably out [__] around so right you
know what I mean like I said as long as
everyone's on the same I think it's
pretty open and everything and
everything everyone's fine with it and
everyone has you know we have parameters
of what then that's fine that's fine as
long as no one's lying to anybody yeah
um
but yeah so uh so yeah so Tammy fade
said around this time they're really
kind of like you know Jim was just so
into his projects and everything he
wasn't really paying much attention to
her anymore
um and they were getting like very
distant from one another
so in 1978 so like I said this is quite
a while ago
um they started building the Christian
theme the Christian theme park that I
mentioned earlier which is called
Heritage USA because their compound
before was called Heritage Village so
they built this big theme park and it's
in South Carolina
um I don't know if it's there anymore
but like at the time that they built it
it was one of the most popular theme
parks in the United States now you have
to think this was like in the 70s and
there weren't a lot of theme parks other
than like Disneyland and Disney World so
you know what I mean like a lot of the
theme parks we had back in the 70s were
kind of lame so so uh you know this one
was kind of popular
um and they had like almost five million
visitors a year which is crazy super
chats are active people in case uh case
you don't know I haven't seen a single
Super Chat up there I'm passing the
plate passing the goddamn collection
plate just like a television look at all
the work Jenny did on this [__] show
it's a fun show to do actually it's a
fun show though yeah yeah I mean this is
this is a fun topic well it's not I mean
it's kind of depressing but it's not
depressing in the same way that a lot of
the [__] that we talk about is so you
know what I mean at least we can kind of
like goof on it and not feel too bad
um but yeah so basically it's kind of
like
obviously by the time that the 80s had
rolled around and they'd kind of become
a little bit of a punch line and because
of all the money they were clearly
spending they weren't like real
secretive about it
um they also found out that in night in
1987 uh there was a big Revelation that
Jim had allegedly used about
279 thousand dollars I've heard 350 000
also uh money from PTL like so money
from that was donated to the praise the
Lord club or whatever
um and he was trying to buy The Silence
of Jessica Hahn who at the time was 21
years old she was a Church secretary and
she uh made the claim
that Jim had sexually assaulted her in a
hotel in Florida in 1980.
and the uh these allegations were going
to go public so he attempted to kind of
make an end run about it by giving his
friend who was one of the guys that was
the builder that worked on Heritage USA
that actually married Tammy Faye later
on like after Jim after her and Jim
divorced but he was the one that um
offered her the money yeah and Jessica
I haven't seen her in a long time but
back
in the 80s 90s [__]
um styles she was hot back then stacked
nice figure
long dark hair and [__] she ended up
being doing some [__] layouts later
on now that she got him thank you very
much thank you Jeffy thank you Jeffy
what do you say Sound of My Last Two
Dollars until payday don't give us your
last two dollars
thank you
but uh you could have bought like a
burrito with that or something yeah but
uh no
[__] I can understand how how Jessica
caught his attention I was under the
impression though that based on the
totality of what I had heard she was a
church groupie
Jessica was she was gunning for big
bucks
trying to land her a big time preacher
because these guys were the rock stars
of their era in a certain way well I
mean if you were in certain circles in
certain circles I mean we had good rock
stars yeah this is in the 80s this was
like the lame yeah
it's just got I hate to say it it's like
I don't know I don't pick on Christians
all the time but it's like the whole
Christian entertainment
sub genre if we want to call it that is
like second rate yeah it's just never as
good and it's like they just can't
manage it no and that's still True to
this day like if you um have some money
to
blow uh go get a subscription to Pure
Flix which is like the Christian Netflix
or better yet just like watch free
YouTube videos of people like making fun
of the [__] that's on there because in
case because then you don't have to
actually watch it and like kill your
brain cells but it's just never
and I don't understand why like I said
there's this really good book I know I I
bring it up a lot but it's called
Rapture Ready I can't remember the name
of the guy that wrote it but he spent
like a couple of years like researching
like all this Christian entertainment
like he went to Christian theme parks
and like movie studios and all this
other kind of stuff and he was kind of
delving into that questions like why is
Christian entertainment like usually not
as good and it's actually it's I mean
the book is funny but it's actually like
kind of insightful I thought I actually
should re-read it reread it because it's
been a couple years but um yeah it's
just it's never quite as good but I
guess like if you grew up in that
in that scene in that environment then
maybe somebody like Jim Baker would seem
like
so I'm like he did have a lot of money I
mean you know what I mean
so yeah so after this whole scandal
uh came out and apparently like I said
it was when they were looking into his
books
because there had been
um
not even rumors there was actually proof
of like Financial malfeasance like going
back to the 1970s and it had been
brought to the attention of various
government bodies that have been brought
to the attention to the IRS FCC
everything like that but they hadn't
done anything about it
so but when the allegations came out
that he had actually tried to pay hush
money to Jessica Hahn for you know
shutting up about whatever had happened
in 1980 that was when everything kind of
came to the fore and they realized that
they had been misappropriating funds
essentially like what they were doing
was the same thing that Kenneth Copeland
and them were doing the same thing the
correct blue dollar and all of them kind
of do they're just like oh we need all
this money to build a new church in you
know Africa or we needed all this money
for like Haitian disaster victims or we
need this and that and the other and
then they use that money just like oh
never mind I'm gonna buy a 500 million
dollar mansion or some [__] like that
you know what I mean it's that's what
they were doing so I kind of feel like
that's
um what Jim and Tammy Faye were doing
how long ago how long have we gone
um two hours and 30. time for
commercials yeah yeah okay then we'll
then we'll continue with that yeah I
mean I'm almost well I'm almost done
we'll do that and then we'll do
commercials and then we'll talk about
Ted Haggard and then I gotta go to bed
okay because I got to get up at five in
the morning yeah and then we got a party
a day after and then well yeah who needs
sleep I'll sleep when I'm dead you'll be
all right but um I'm always all right
I'm gonna make you some high protein
[__] so you'll be nice I I need some
caffeine is what happens is what I need
all right probably
um but yeah so that was kind of the
thing that they mostly got in trouble
for it wasn't so much I feel like he
didn't really get I feel like people
weren't as mad about the alleged sexual
assault as they were about the
misappropriation of funds because what
they were doing was that
um essentially they had spent so much
money that they were in danger of going
bankrupt like I said they were bringing
in almost five million dollars a month
but they were spending more than seven
million dollars a month just and it was
usually on their [__] you know what I
mean like fancy houses and yeah because
they had a bunch of
homes and all kind of like cars and all
kind of crazy [__]
so they started um so a criminal
investigation was launched in 1987. now
for a time as you usually see in these
types of situations with these kind of
Evangelical things uh Tammy Faye looked
like she was standing by her man you
know what I mean uh they went on Ted
Koppel which they actually showed in the
movie they had the real footage of like
a couple but not but with the actors
yeah so they like put it I forgot all
about tech cop but they were yeah I was
going man I forgot all about that dick
and he was like interviewing yeah on
Nightline yeah and so they I mean they
weren't real substantive on there they
were basically like yeah um okay it was
all cool TV was not substantive well you
know yeah it was just it was they were
just they were [__] shamming their
way through it and bullshitting you
through the way they were like Jesus
loves you at the end you know trying to
like they were trying to like make the
best of it YouTube has changed the game
you get a lot more information through
YouTube than you ever did through retro
television ever yeah yeah Oracle said I
need to skedaddle folks okay
around see you around thank you for
dropping by like I said this has gone on
like longer than I thought but but I did
like I said this is this is a fun topic
so yeah I'm kind of glad I'll like I
said I'll sleep when I'm dead so um so
yeah
so they're on there but Jim
eventually gets indicted in 1988. uh
eight counts of mail fraud 15 counts of
wire fraud one count of conspiracy he
initially got sentenced to 45 years in
federal prison uh but it eventually got
whittled down to eight years so you know
because like I said it's it wasn't so
much the I don't think he was even
charged with like the sexual assault it
was mostly like misappropriation of
funds
was all that so yeah so they sent him to
jail now he was in jail for three years
and then Tammy Faye uh served him with
divorce papers now she got kind of raked
over the coals about that but I mean
what the [__] do you want a girl to do
Jesus Christ
you know what I'm saying it was time for
that and well well she was basically
saying she's like look um if I'd waited
until he got out of prison it's like by
the way I want a divorce that's that
would have been [__] up yeah and I
mean she didn't say that but that's that
was the sentiment then she wasted eight
years of her life right and she was like
look our marriage has been shitty for a
long time and it's just like you know I
I've been miserable for a long time so
it's just like I'm doing this now so you
know give the girl a break like I said
now a year after the divorce was made
final Tammy Faye actually married the
guy who was uh his name was Roe Messer
he was actually in the movie you know
the guy that came there uh talking to uh
Jim Baker about the Park yeah and she
came out and was like talking when she
was kind of she was super high and she
was that that was that actor was playing
the yeah she married him later bro
Master his name was
so he was the guy that was the builder
the contractor that built uh their theme
park yeah so um so they got married uh
you know a year after she divorced uh
Jim now interestingly Man Tammy can
really pick him can't she because Roe
was also convicted of bankruptcy fraud
in 1994 and actually served 27 months in
prison so a little over two years
um now so Tammy Faye was still married
to him when she died in 2007. uh she
actually had colon cancer and she man
she struggled with it for 11 years and
she was very very open about all the
chemotherapy and everything like that
she was always on TV and everything was
talking about it ate her down to nothing
it did yeah she at one point she said uh
before she died like when she was in
hospice I think they said she was down
to 65 pounds which is [__] crazy I
mean she's small she's only 4 11 but
still like that somebody said but holy
crap 11 years yeah that's the size of uh
our friend yeah yeah but um but yeah she
died in 2007 at age 65.
um and she said that she was still
friends with Jim Baker like all the rest
of her life Kaylee died of the same
thing yeah well wait was it Cola cancer
same thing just ate her up yeah from the
inside I couldn't eat anything just
shitty went down to nothing poor girl so
uh yeah so then Jim Baker who like I
said just because there's no justice in
the universe is still alive
um he got paroled in 1994.
and then in 2003
um he went back to broadcasting uh with
the Jim Baker show and he co-host with
his second wife whose name is Lori
uh they got married in 1998 and as I
mentioned before because the whole
hopeful happy clappy thing wasn't
working out for him so much anymore he
decided to go full on apocalyptic end
times Jesus is coming back everyone's
gonna die holy [__] type of thing uh so
he does that he's basically talking
about end times prophecy now and selling
apocalyptic food products and that kind
of [__] uh and he's also written uh
several books one of which is called
Time Has Come how to prepare now for
epic events ahead yeah it's this I
definitely would not be looking to Jim
Baker for advice in that Arena but you
know what do I know uh and he also
founded something called Morningside
Church in Blue Eye Missouri and also
re-established the PTL Ministry so this
[__] is still around doing [__]
even though he was in prison because you
know
people still believe it I guess a lot of
famous Christians out of the Bible were
in prison and got out Daniel and all
that I guess yeah I'm not you know I
don't not casting his versions I'm just
saying Jesus was in prison and executed
by the Romans
it all plays into the motif the whole
reason that he went to prison though was
because was for the very specific reason
that he had misappropriated funds people
were sending him money ostensibly for
one thing and he was using it for other
things one of one of those things being
to pay off a woman that he either raped
or had sex with like extra marital sex
with yeah so um you would think that
people would be like yeah I'm not gonna
send that [__] any money anymore
but yet people still do I have a feeling
that Jessica that he had sex with
Jessica Hahn and then she wanted him to
pay up that's what I think or the rape
accusations would happen that was my
take on it
probably true
but couldn't happen to a nicer guy yeah
I mean it couldn't happen he's not a
great person so I'm not going to get too
man this is
anybody involved with the mega churches
is not
they're not on the up and up I don't
it's like Scientology why are you
why you know why are you having
compassion for scientologists they [__]
each other over [__] constantly
because that they didn't have a choice
yeah but if you join later on yeah I
ain't worried about you I I'm not really
all that worried about you because you
should know better right you should know
better all right so let's do some
commercials and then we'll talk about
Ted Haggard and then we'll wrap it up
because I did want to talk about TED
hacks all right all right so we're gonna
do some commercials and we'll be back a
few minutes just a couple minutes
now doesn't it
[Music]
is
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
all right we're back
so uh Ben brings up something which
thank you for bringing this up because I
almost forgot to mention this
um talking about Jim Baker said was he
actually convicted of doing it what was
he actually convicted of doing illegal I
thought it was because he was
deliberately double booking people in
his theme park hotel to Swindle them
across state lines that was one of the
issues
um what he would do is that he would
charge like he had these two I think it
was two like luxury hotels that he had
like either in Heritage Village or on
the theme park uh Heritage USA with
Browns and he if you paid
I can't remember how much it was I think
it was fifteen hundred dollars or two
thousand dollars or something like that
like you paid you bought like a lifetime
membership and this lifetime membership
which was a couple thousand dollars
um would entitle you to stay for three
nights at this one of these hotels like
every year but he overbooked like there
was more people
um that paid for Lifetime memberships
than would be able to like you know
mathematically like stay there for three
nights every year
so he got in trouble for that as well so
yeah so thanks for bringing that up
because that was one of the things and
he knew and he did that like knowing
that that that there was no way that
he'd be able to honor any of that kind
of [__] but he seemed like he didn't
really care about it
um so yeah all right so let's talk about
uh finally let's talk about Ted Haggard
because Ted Haggard this was like a
slightly more recent this was like in
the 2000s like the early to mid 2000s
now Ted Haggard
he started out he's actually from uh
Indiana and his uh dad he was kind of
one of the ones that didn't super come
from like a you know
evangelist background I guess because
his dad was a veterinarian but his dad
also did found a charismatic Ministry so
I guess there was some of that in there
now
I will get into this in a little bit but
Ted hagger did later say that as a
seven-year-old he was sexually molested
I don't want to get into a thing of like
questioning people who say that they've
been abused as children because I know
that does happen a lot but in this case
I don't know if he just said that to
like maybe exonerate himself of like
some [__] he did later on so I don't
know I'm just I'm remaining neutral on
that
so basically when he was 16 years old he
became a born-again Christian
after hearing a sermon uh in Dallas
Texas by a dude named Bill bright who is
an evangelist and also he's a big fan of
C.S Lewis uh who you know yeah he wrote
The Lion the Witch and the Wardrobe
which is an awesome book and everything
like The Chronicles of Narnia but he was
also a Christian apologist and wrote A
Lot in that vein
so
um so Ted at the time he wanted to be as
a teenager he wanted to be a journalist
and he was actually going to go to
college and study journalism
but then the story goes that his dad
offered him offered to buy him a Pontiac
LeMans which I guess at the time was
like a very fancy yeah it was cool car
like a cool car yeah if he would go to
Oral Roberts University like I said we
mentioned like a lot of televangelists
did actually go to Oral Roberts
University so uh Ted wanted that car so
he said okay will do give him on my
Pontiac Lamont I want my body so uh so
he gave up his dreams of Journalism and
went to Oral Roberts University so he
said that while he was there uh he felt
the the call of God I guess God called
him on the phone it was like hey go be
an evangelist I don't know I don't know
how that works
um but so yeah so he went to Oral
Roberts and then he um went to Baton
Rouge and was kind of like an associate
pastor down there
and had another Revelation uh that
actually I think his friend had a
revelation that he was going to open up
a church in Colorado Springs so he went
to Colorado Springs and did open a
church but at first it was just like a
congregation in his basement so it was
just like 20 people come to the basement
of his house
um which is crazy because it grew into
like a massive
uh you know 14
000 person congregation like by the
early 1990s which is insane
um religious big businessman it is yeah
and it's like like I said if I didn't
have a conscience I could probably like
make a lot of questions
we can make a [__] ton of cash yeah but
yeah so I mean it grew like really quick
like I said starting out with 20 people
in your basement and then going to 14
000 people that's like pretty crazy and
later on they had like 300 different
congregations and eventually it would
become a big mega church and by the time
2005 rolled around which like I said was
only like 10 12 years later
um Ted Haggard was actually in Time
Magazine as one of the top 25 most
influential evangelicals in America
called up uh then President George W
bush all like every week like to advise
him on [__] I guess
um you know during the election and all
that uh and was seen as kind of one of
the most
um you know prevalent evangelicals he
had the year of uh a lot of the kind of
Republican whatever at that yeah for you
people who are not in the United States
the weird thing about the Republican
party is that they would have had a lot
of problems winning elections if they
didn't have these religious groups on
their sides so the Republican party in
this era was cow towering to these
religious groups a lot
was the Republican Party religious no it
wasn't it just would use any means it
needed it needed to win and and both
parties were like that they just they
count out to anybody this whatever the
voting blocks were that's what they did
so yeah so I guess like at what Okay so
so Haggard was like talking to Bush all
the time like I said was on in Time
Magazine all this other kind of stuff
however
in November of 2006
a man named Mike Jones came forward
Mike Jones was a masseuse and also a sex
worker
and said that not only had Ted Haggard
paid him for sex multiple times over a
three-year period but had also on
numerous occasions bought Crystal Meth
from him
and had used it
now Mike said well I didn't know who Ted
Haggard was which like I said why would
you yeah because he's just a customer
he's just a customer and he said he
didn't use his real name he went by Art
yeah and he said the only reason I found
out who he was is because I was watching
something on TV about at that time in
2006 in Colorado
um there was something called Amendment
43 which was going to ban gay marriage
in the state
and he saw Ted Haggard on there talking
about because he supported uh Banning
gay marriage ironically
um so Mike was kind of like that
[__] like he's on there like
he's been [__] me for three years and
yet he's on here like saying gay
marriage is wrong so he's like [__] that
dude so he's you know wanted to point
out the hypocrisy hoping that people
would not vote for it which like you
know which is understandable
so he came forward at that time saying
yeah this dude has been you know coming
to me for three years
so when the story broke
shortly before the vote
Ted Haggard um immediately denied it
uh categorically I mean he pretty much
he's like I basically said I did not
have sex with him
um I haven't had sex with anyone other
than my wife and he also said I've never
done drugs not even he doesn't even
drink wine there's not even any wine in
the house he doesn't even drink alcohol
I'm like come on you're laying it on a
little bit thick now
um we just we just don't do we don't
smoke we don't do any of that stuff
that's what he says
now because he came out and denied it
like a lot of other
um the religious leaders at the time
including James Dobson of focus on the
family Fame uh came forward and defended
him oh it's like everyone's picking on
him it's like it's just the media
they're trying to
um you know besmirch his name because
they don't like this Vote or whatever
and they were just like you know they're
just making all this stuff up and why
would they report this about this
wonderful honorable man
blah blah blah you know what I mean
now uh turned out though that Mike the
masseuse had still had a lot of Ted's
voicemails
so you know that's that's the lesson
there if you're gonna do like this
download [__] maybe get a burner phone
just just a pro tip
um but yeah because so Mike had all of
these uh voicemails
where uh Ted specifically asked to buy
quantities of Meth
when confronted with this new
information Ted backtracks a little bit
because remember before I've never done
drugs I've never done any of that stuff
oh well okay I did buy meth but I didn't
take it
which you know what I mean he's just
backing up by the grease you know
because when you get caught in something
you just have to keep I bought it but I
was tempted and I bought it but then I
threw it away and I never took it that's
what he said which is come on now
um and he said uh actually Mike the
accuser he there's another one there's
another one where he took a polygraph
test
and I guess he didn't do that well on it
so uh Ted got all excited about that but
like I said you know they're they're not
super reliable
now
at this point even though he was still
denying the sex part he did Ted did like
admit that he bought meth but he didn't
say that he took it even though that's
obviously crap
but he decided or he was made to decide
that he should be put on administrative
leave from his you know Ministry that he
started which is called New Life
Ministry if I didn't mention that
um he basically says I'm gonna step
aside because you know all of this
Scandal and I can't you know properly
minister to people yada yada
uh so I'm just gonna take a break and do
that
and a little while later like other
Church officials later came forward to
the media and said um Ted actually
admitted to us that yeah he did most of
that [__] that he denied doing you know
what I mean so he told us about that
um
so yeah and then
he made it so it's like yeah I bought
meth and I went to Mike Jones for a
massage
um but then he but then he was still
denying the sex and so denying taking
the drugs
like I said The more like the more
information comes out like the more he's
about oh well okay well okay I did that
but not that you know what I mean it's
just like it's so silly he just gave me
a massage yeah there was no way at the
ending there was no smoking mad come on
yeah I mean
like I said look if you want to smoke
math you smoke meth and have all this
stuff she wants the Kitty's coming in
but don't come out and and be like a
powerful Evangelical figure and be like
you guys would like we need to ban gay
marriage when you're [__] dudes and
smoking meth but I didn't marry him like
I would never marry that man that that's
the that's the rationale but I'm sure it
probably that is the ration that is
[__] up that's the restaurant no you
can get all the hand jobs you want you
could do that they always find a way to
justify it down in the motherfucker's
booty it doesn't but I'm not I didn't
marry him I didn't marry him that that's
the thinking yeah you're too sane you're
not you're not insane enough to
understand well
well the thing about well I'm
I'm not like it's insulting or something
but it's like insane I do understand it
like intellectually I understand their
thought process yeah I don't have that
thought process
um you know so I can't relate but I do
from an intellectual standpoint what do
they understand what are they going to
say are they going to say yes that's
what I mean are they going to say I kind
of feel like people would have are they
going to always be alive yeah here's the
thing they can't say that if you're a
famous person whether you're a religious
figure evangelist or just a movie star
or whatever the [__] and you get caught
doing some bad I'm not talking about
like child porn or nothing like that but
I'm just talking about dude [__] like
this you know what I mean
um which like I said everyone's
concerning adults you know it's not that
big of a deal like to normal people
so you get caught doing some [__] like
that I kind of feel like it would
behoove you I think people would have a
lot more respect for you and I think you
would your comeback would happen a lot
quicker if you would just admit it
quit prolonging the [__] by denial
because you deny it you're making it
worse you're making it worse because
eventually people are gonna find out the
[__] and then you're gonna look bad
because you piled lying on yeah but
you're not you're not the Christian
audience he's only playing to the
Christian audience well I get that those
are the ones that are paying him
and he can't say that to them he can't
or though they won't pay him
but see the thing about it like if
you're an evangelist though you have a
get out of jail free card because you
can just say the devil tempted me and I
[__] up that's true but they're not
against it
now I'm asking Jesus to forgive me
that's all you got to say don't like
don't prolong it don't deny it exactly
it's dumb don't do that you're just
making things worse for yourself Zach
how's this go just admit it the devil
possessed me I had to jump up and land
on that dick ass first it was just it
was possession it was demonic possession
there was nothing more of them don't
pull that out that's what that's what
they should have done I mean it's it's
right there and a lot of people believe
that they don't have a [__] thing
then you have a whole thing two or three
weeks of possession exorcism episodes
you could get a lot of questions a lot
of mileage they're exercising the gay
out of you right that's but see they're
not creative though oh these these dudes
are not as intelligent as you think they
are that's what I would do and they're
they're right I don't think they're very
intelligent they're not intelligent
yeah I know they're not intelligent I'm
just saying I'm just saying if it was it
we like just from uh from that
standpoint yeah I just think it's better
if they were more intelligent they would
have been above the table comedians or
entertainers you know what I mean
instead of doing instead of doing this
right [__] this is like bottom of
the barrel entertainment
which is what they are they're
entertainers yeah they just can't
they're they don't understand it most
people and they can't cut it and they
can't kill their world yeah that's what
it is they can't cut it so it's like
it's the same thing they have to be
famous in this little thing is a
Christian metal band okay yeah they can
make metal music but they can't cut it
against the [__] against a real
satanic [__] black metal Slayer yeah
yeah no they can't they can't cut it you
could you can only be famous in that
like right small that's what's happening
ghetto or better yeah yeah Lord help me
devil jumped in me and I had to jump on
a dick
[__] save me and all that kind of
stuff yeah yeah save me
and like a lot of your followers are
already probably yeah yeah [__] it's
like I don't understand almost eroticize
it sure and even like come out and give
details juicy details that little old
ladies would love yeah they would love
that they would love this it was like
out of the Harlequin novels and [__] and
they would be [__] sending you all
kinds of money but they're not that
creative they can't they can't see the
entertainment value in that
they're entertainers but they're not
real good ones that's why they're doing
this yeah right because you give me this
[__] gig and I'll run that [__] into
the ground all right every little old
lady and every [__] trailer would be
sending me all kinds of money
that's what I mean you could you could
go dirty with it [__] run
talk about how I had to pimp myself out
because of [__] Dubai and oh my God
yeah there's nothing I could do about it
I was [__] possessed possessed by the
power of [__] [__] it was pulling
yeah all this homoerotic [__] and these
women to be spending all this [__]
money man yeah hell yeah be right out of
the [__] Harley Quinn novels
making some money
but they can't do it they can't think
that way
I wonder why I wonder if it's you're too
conventional yeah I kind of feel like
it's because deep down I think they
really kind of on some level do kind of
believe in this yeah they're too they're
too mundane and like I said they can't
really I had to hype this they're not
cynical [__] like we yeah right yeah
Jeffy Hart says the power of [__]
compels you
yes it does save me save me from those
uncircumcised penises I mean that's
that's great so yeah
so he okay so at this point Ted has only
admitted getting a massage from Mike and
buying meth but not using it
but even that
um because remember how I said like
Jerry Falwell and Pat Robertson and all
those [__] like they stood up
for the dude but after he admitted just
that much they were like yeah no I'm
backing away slowly you know what I mean
so there was that kind of whole
situation
um so and then and I guess the president
like Bush wasn't calling him anymore
either it's like yeah no I'm just gonna
like dissociate from that situation
because that's about to blow up
so
um basically then they did uh the
overseer of the New Life Church which is
the church that Ted Haggard founded uh
they did a
uh you know kind of investigation and
even though this is like hilarious to me
so even though Ted Haggard had like
founded the New Life Church I guess like
the dude he put in charge of like the
overseeing board or whatever they fired
him like that's like for doing this [__]
because they said we did the
investigation and we figured out that he
totally did all that [__] that he said
he didn't do
um what they called sexually immoral
conduct
so they're like yeah get out so they
actually sent him to some weird hardcore
counseling kind of like conversion
therapy
um you know where they like pray the gay
way I heard I don't know if this is true
or not but I heard they even did like
weird like Scientology type [__] like
lie detector tests and yeah uh you know
sleep deprivation and all that kind of
crap that pray the gay wave movie that
we saw in the theater was [__] great
Zach needs to see the boy erased boy
erased Zach you need to see that movie I
think Natalie uh what's her name Nicole
Kidman was in that yeah boy erased it's
it's a masterpiece and there's and it
just came and went vanished
there's actually a documentary about
conversion therapy on Netflix I was
actually gonna watch it last night but I
was too tired but it's so funny because
the dudes doing the conversion therapy
on him to try to turn him [__]
straight
we're gay
turned out they were gay well I think
the whole thing was that look it worked
on me except yeah
that whole thing is a [__] show well so
like I think a lot it was a [__] show I
think a lot of [__] um states don't
even roll out of that anymore a lot of
countries don't allow that anymore
either because that's some [__]
don't [__] people up like that come on
but um yeah so so I don't know so I
think they did like a version of that
on Ted Haggard like he went into some
kind of conversion therapist and then
um so he went through this whatever it
was for I think three weeks
and then at the end of the three weeks
the ministers that did it came out and
said he's fixed he's completely 100
heterosexual and I was like wow just
like magic I'm like that's totally how
it works yeah
uh so yeah so now he resigned Ted did in
November of 2006.
and after he resigned he admitted yeah I
use the math duh everybody knows you did
and also uh Mike Jones jerked me off
yeah
got a happy ending [__] I knew the
[__] got a happy head the
hilarious thing was at first he was
trying to think well I just went to him
for a massage but then it went terribly
awry yes I hate when that happens you
deserve for a massage then you end up
yeah then all of a sudden the [__]
ending was happy I don't know how did it
happen I couldn't resist the hand cream
I had to [__] a hand cream man it was so
it was smelled like coconut I was just
laying back like that I had the
headphones on I didn't know what
happened
I was just done with cliff
I'm just going with the flow there's
nothing I could do about it it wasn't a
game
manly men or amongst other manly men
doing manly manly things they just
couldn't stop
couldn't stop what a man wanted to do
you know
you know it was just my penis got the
best of me
it took over yeah dick took over you
know what I mean I couldn't stop it yeah
you did right Zach
by another man in a year how would you
know that
I don't know I'm baiting them I'm
beating him I'm gonna get him out here
I don't know all right but yeah so uh
so so at least he admitted that much
but then a couple years later
in 2009 uh there was actually a
documentary that came out the debating
him I'm a masturbator yeah yeah
you had to get that in there so this
documentary comes out which is called
the trials of Ted Haggard and it was
kind of about him I don't know if he was
necessarily like trying to play the
victim but what the thing that happened
was that when he got
um essentially fired from his position
at new life and they said okay well
will give you and your wife whose name
is Gail
we'll give you guys like a very generous
severance package I think they paid them
each like 138 000 a year plus expenses
like living expenses and [__] like that
I'm like wow must be nice so uh anyway
so they said we'll give you all that but
one of the stipulations was that he
couldn't preach anymore and like for a
period of time and he had to move out of
Colorado Springs which is like so funny
that like another like a religious body
can tell you you can't live in this town
anymore and I was like excuse me I can
live wherever I want it's a free [__]
country but you know what I mean so
they're design comes back to kind of
[__] confirm that he is getting
action you get action okay I got you I
got you that yeah I thought he was like
I said that's why I don't know and Andy
gave you some action
good man but yeah so so apparently these
[__] told him it's like well
that's one of the stipulations of you
getting the money I guess they couldn't
like basically say you know you have to
get out of town or we'll kill you or
whatever but they're like you won't get
the money unless you leave Colorado
Springs so he did actually leave like
him and his wife moved to Phoenix for a
little while but then uh it turned out
that more [__] started coming out
um that there was a guy another guy that
came forward like a young uh church
member who came forward in 2006 and said
that there was inappropriate sexual in
in the sense I think what he was getting
at was that Ted Haggard was like jerking
it like in front of him all the time and
he wasn't a fan no um like he was doing
it against the kid's will like he kept
pulling out like exposing himself and
stuff like that pulling out and jerking
it in front of the kid man right right
yeah
um I mean I don't think he was a kid kid
but I think he was like young I think he
was like 18 19 20 something like that he
was legal so um well he was but some of
the later people were now yeah uh so and
yeah he said it happened like multiple
times now did they have a religious
[__] excuse for this
I mean one thing I will give to Ted
Haggard he's a terrible human being
but he's not quite as terrible as some
of it like he's still terrible like
don't get me wrong but it's it's a you
know it's kind of like a spectrum of
terribleness and Ted Haggard
he actually did do a couple of cool
things in the sense that he seemed not
quite as Prosperity Gospel he wasn't
like as money hungry the church that he
founded he actually had a really good
um pay system set up it was solely based
on seniority because I guess Church
systems before were always based on your
position it's like this person makes
like a [__] ton of money and this person
doesn't make anything he's the way he
had it set up was that
um everybody there
um made like a lot of money and like you
made more money like the longer you were
there but that was the only stipulation
like for making more money it wasn't
like anything to do with your possession
or anything position it was having to do
with like Senor Lake how long he'd been
there so he had like a much more
Equitable pay structure and he seemed to
have like a pretty cool like laid-back
it's weird because he really did seem to
come out against gay marriage and stuff
like that but he seemed to have
I I don't know at least on the surface
he seemed like um to encourage people to
be more like non-judgmental of other
people's Lifestyles and like not
I don't know he just seemed more like I
mean he still had a lot of terrible [__]
going on
but he wasn't quite as bad as some of
the other ones so I don't know why he
wasn't just open with all this stuff
because like I said it's just dumb
because you're gonna get caught like
eventually if you're doing it was the
time stuff like flagrantly I mean and
this was a little bit later this was
like mid to late 2000s so this wasn't
like the 80s yeah yeah like you could
have still come out like back then it
wouldn't have been quite as I mean it's
not as accepting as now but like you
know it was still a lot more accepting
than the 80s that's for sure
so uh so yeah so this guy that came
forward and said that you know
essentially Ted Haggard was like jerking
it in front of him all the time
um was uh you know what I mean so he was
basically like uh that guy they found
out later that his name was Grant Haas
and the church actually gave him a
payoff
um 179 000 I believe it was
um you know they paid his college
tuition and stuff like that like to I
guess is compensatory
um now Ted Haggard did actually admit to
doing the [__] that Grant hot said he
did um on CNN
and uh they asked him but you know an
understandable question they're like
well have there been any other
relationships that you're not like
telling us about and he wouldn't answer
so yeah a lot of them yeah probably now
later on as recently as July of 2022 uh
there were new allegations against Ted
Haggard
um the most recent ones being made by a
guy named Seth sethman or Kirk sethman
but he's called Seth sethman uh he was
actually ordained a minister of St James
Church which is the church that Ted
Haggard founded like after he got run
out of town like on the other one he
found it in 2012.
and basically
um
Kirk sethman came forward and said that
there were two uh men young men who said
that Ted Haggard had uh you know it
touched them like inappropriately like
against their will like um at the church
uh one of them was at the time of the
incidents was a minor when the incidents
happened in 2019
and uh Church Elders had been approached
but apparently had nothing had been
really done about it so like I said
after Ted got kicked out of uh of
wherever he was before uh Colorado
Springs he got moved to Phoenix Arizona
and they started like I said they
these people now Ted Haggard he didn't
have as much money as the others like
you know he was a poor obviously because
they were giving him 138 thousand
dollars and Gail was getting some to you
so you know don't cry too hard you know
he wasn't a millionaire or anything like
that but and evidently at least
according to the documentary The Trials
of Ted Haggard he did actually have to
get a quote-unquote real job like he had
to get a job selling Insurance
um after their severance pay ran out but
he was still able to
kind of apply his name and fame into
another church because the thing about
it was that even though
he had been accused of these other
things like I said as recently as 2022
one of them against a minor at the
church
um he was still able to start another
church like yeah he started it in his
barn like on his property or whatever
but people still go there and people
still
give him money and like listen to him
and [__] like that which is crazy to me
I don't understand like why everybody's
just like nope nothing more to do with
that person but you know
it's that's I don't know that's crazy to
me so
um God man God I guess you can get away
with pretty much anything I suppose now
as I mentioned earlier later on I don't
know if Ted ever said anything about
this prior to the accusations against
him coming out
but he did say later on that he was
molested as a child which like I said
I'm not gonna say that that's not true
because it's very possible that it could
be but I don't know if he was just
saying that to sort of exonerate himself
or sort of like take the edge off of the
accusations against him maybe like to
give himself a little bit of an excuse
but I'm I don't know I don't know if
that's the case or if maybe he was
molested I don't really know
um but he basically came out and said
that but then he's like well I don't
want that I don't want people to think
that that's just an excuse for what
happened because I don't excuse it now
once he I mean he denied denied denied
but then once he finally admitted it I
kind of feel like he was kind of all in
with it which okay I I kind of wish he'd
done that from the beginning
but you know
um he's just kind of one of those
[__] like I said if he had not
been so prominent in coming out against
gay marriage for example I don't think
anyone would have cared as much but the
fact that he was so powerful
um you know politically and that he was
coming out against this particular law
which a lot of people didn't like and
you know and then the fact that he was
doing all that [__] on the down low and
then denying it I mean that makes people
mad and understandably so I mean I get
mad about that because like I said I
don't like that kind of like oh I can do
what I want but you can't type of [__] I
don't like that hypocrisy yeah I don't
like hypocrisy I just really don't
so um I mean that's the thing here's the
weird thing his wife Gail they have five
kids him and his wife
um and she stuck by him the whole
[__] time as far as I know they're
still married
um in this you're gonna love this in
2012 you remember that show Celebrity
Wife Swap
so Ted Haggard and his wife Gail I heard
of it never watched it where I never
watched it either I've heard of it
though yeah
Ted Haggard and his wife Gail were on
there and Gail
got swapped with the wife so she went
and lived with Gary Busey oh [__] and
I'm now I was like drunk I saw that and
I was like oh my God I have to see that
I have to see that I think he's homeless
isn't he I wonder how that worked out
not well sure I mean
I've read that like a Wikipedia I was
like you have got to be [__] kidding
me I gotta find that right now I really
gotta see that but yeah so the fact that
I don't know the fact that she stayed
with him all the time that's crazy
because those people are freakier than
you think that well now I know they are
I know they are and the thing about it I
think a lot of them stay they wouldn't
be in that [__] if they were if they
were I mean a lot of them stayed
together back in the old days because of
appearances because it's like you know
and particularly I think they even said
about Jim and Tammy Baker like when we
were watching the thing like even then
like in those circles like divorce was
still like very frowned upon which is
crazy to think about but um so they
almost kind of had to stay together for
a while even though there was all that
going on but
I don't know I kind of feel like in this
day and age
I don't think anybody would have been
mad at her for being like yeah [__] this
[__] but she didn't she stayed she's
still there I'm just looking at your
beautiful head my beautiful head it's so
beautiful I got my golf girlfriend back
look at her yeah yeah
she looking beautiful love her head
are you doing this again I'm doing this
again it's affection Zach says uh so she
lived with Gary Busey's lips is what I'm
hearing in his teeth evidently
um yeah I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have
to watch that at some point and then
maybe we'll report back and see because
I was just something like oh my God I
bet that's like freaking really
entertaining swapping wives with Gary
Busey's wife
interestingly and this all I'll end on
this note
so Ted Haggard did an interview with GQ
in 2011. and he said I think that
probably if I were 21 in this Society I
would identify myself as bisexual
just like and they asked and they asked
him it's like well why don't you do that
now
I mean I mean people are [__] freaks
and they're that's what I mean and
they're like well can't you just do that
now I mean what's the big deal yeah
um but basically I think he was like
well he said and I was like this is a
little bit of a backhanded compliment
but he said oh well I have you know a
wife and kids and it's like they like
their ordinary life
yeah that's what he said he doesn't want
to go sideways on him and do do like do
you like freaky [__] dude freaky [__]
well but he does freaky [__] he just
does it on the down low and I was like
maybe your wife would have like a lot
more respect for you if you just said
like look before you did anything you
could have just said hey I'm having this
like I want to do this that the other
and see him like you know run it by her
look
I'm gonna just you know she might have
said no I don't know I've had me and Jen
came from the course [__] goth
subculture lots of gay people we have
lots of gay friends
my best friend right now or my best club
friends is a [__] leather daddy okay
Toby
um
just known a lot of gay people and and
uh the good people they're just regular
dudes you know well everyone is they're
just regular dudes but I'll tell you one
thing though
[__] Zach probably backed me up on
this
when it comes to creep vibes
closeted dudes or the or the creeps okay
just we'll see they're not who they're
that's what I mean that's what I was
gonna say anybody that is trying to
portraying the false yeah face or is
trying to be something they aren't
whether they're a gay person pretending
to be straight or whether whatever it is
if you're pretending to be something
you're not able to pick up on that and
it's creepy always pick up these [__]
creep Vibes oh [__] dudes that are in
the closet
and that's what these guys are okay
[__] dudes by he's coming yeah okay
but too late man which like I said would
have been fine why didn't you just say
that at the beginning instead of making
this big [__] Rick moral about it
like I you know I almost I'm not
excusing it but I almost understand it
more like in the 80s and stuff like that
because it wasn't acceptable you know
what I mean but nowadays and even in
like 2006 or whenever it was that
happened with Ted Haggard it's like you
could have just said yeah I'm bisexual I
mean yeah the Christians would have been
pissed off about it but everyone else
but I've been like meh the whole thing
about it no one would have cared the
whole thing about it not being
acceptable in the 80s I don't really buy
that either that [__] gay was around
for a long [__] time all right that
[__] was big in the 1920s well you know
what's weird I had [__] in the 1700s
well I know that okay I'm just saying
that I kind of feel like in
culturally at large I kind of feel like
gay was more acceptable in the 70s than
it was in the 80s yeah
I feel like in the in the 80s kind of
[__] went a little bit backwards as long
as you were hanging out with cool people
it didn't really [__] matter well no
I know that but I'm just talking about
I'm talking about mainstream society as
a whole I'm talking about mainstream
society as a whole 70s was seemed more
accepting yeah of gay people in the 70s
than it than in the 80s and maybe that
was just my perception but that was how
I perceived it the problem with a lot of
the um
like uh the of the Christian crowd is
that they they didn't understand history
homosexuality is around for [__] tens
of thousands well it's been around
forever
they have no idea well as long as it's
like it happens in the animal case yeah
well it's not just us
I don't think I know if it's exactly the
same thing but you you even if you look
at if you look at Christianity there's a
lot of stuff that there's a lot of stuff
in Christianity especially the Roman
Church
all right and when you talk about like
Saint Thomas Aquinas you read some of
his writings this just sounds gay to me
okay it's it's like gay mgtow okay
um Christianity is a Roman religion it's
a Roman copy
of G of a Jew of a Jewish sect or a
Jewish religion
the Romans were [__]
openly bi that was the Romans bisexual
especially in the Roman Capital
bisexuality was the standard
now
it wasn't quite the same bisexuality you
have today you were a man was supposed
to outgrow it as he went through his
twenties and then he became a real man
of an alpha like a dominant type man it
was the idea it's just
but that is [__] in has been
intertwined with early Christianity you
know so
in some ways These Guys these bisexual
[__] Evangelistic preachers are kind
of in the treas the Christian tradition
in a certain way
but at their closetedness uh is not all
right
and uh the real guys would have been
[__] kind of like uh according to the
to the scriptures and what they left
behind they were kind of like turning
their back on all sexuality almost like
an Addis cult
and then the cult to Addis you cut your
own dick off
that's quite a sack I mean they were
hardcore that was quite a [__]
sacrifice
a lot of Christianity to me reading you
know especially some of this stuff some
of the some of the uh what do you call
it the poly material
sounds like
a bisexual guy turning away from all
sexuality and to become asexual
in a certain way like he's above all
that now you know he's above normal
dynamic between men and women he's now
part of the priesthood you know
I think that's just gay as [__] it was a
fairly common theme I thought yeah well
because they thought certain sects of
not just Christianity but some religions
in general Yeah
well yeah it was seen as like
animalistic animals Earthly worldly and
it's like so they were trying to like
rise above that and just be like of the
mind of this yeah whatever so it's like
they anything that had to do with
anything physical or anything they kind
of shunned Church art go back to
Michelangelo which is definitely
homoerotic and the [__] church was
buying this [__] well I kind of feel
like everyone's pretty much come to the
terms with the fact that Michelangelo
was probably gay look at Adam and chains
that sculpture that is homoerotic well I
was reading a book about Caravaggio who
was another
um very famous artist whose work was
purchased by churches and he was sure
bisexual yeah
so
um
mundane people have to come to terms
with human nature and human history
we're complicated man yeah human beings
are [__] complicated
and some guys who were gay or bisexual
to get acceptance and to get cleanliness
in their minds was to rise above
Earthly desire
but it was also required of straight men
to do this when they when they entered
the church that way gay and straight men
and bisexual men could all be equal in
the church because they've given they've
given up because nobody was getting any
nobody was getting me we were all part
of this [__]
mgtow we're going to go our own way
meanwhile all the women were like yeah
thank God they're gone right right
Midtown is so funny to me I'm like bye
yeah go now we'll sit around us uh a
spiritual [__] and we'll make
we'll buy erotic art okay and we'll talk
about how holy that is
yeah we jerking and we'll dig up old
Roman art of [__] pants or seder's
[__] she-goats yeah and we'll store
that for our own energy put that in the
cabinet yeah in the bestiality section
you know [__] so yeah
[Laughter]
Jeffy art said this goes back to what
Tom said about closeted men during the
Herb Baumeister podcast if you're gonna
be gay be power gay power gay Tom is
remember oh my God my personal Creed
yeah yeah power through the [__] [__]
you know wear this [__] on your sleeve I
respect that a lot more dude I respect
that like I said my best buddies like
that and I'm just like yes right if
that's what makes me mad about about
people like this and why this was such a
fun shun to do show to do is that I
don't take issue with the [__] they're
doing
you know with the [__] they're doing I
don't take issue with Ted Haggard like I
said having sex with male prostitutes or
taking crystal meth you can do that it's
fine as long as everyone's consenting
adults no one gives a [__] but the fact
that he was actually you know hurting
other people like that by coming out in
support of this law which would aband
gay marriage
um is that's what makes me angry it's
the hypocrisy that makes me angry like I
said if you would just come out if he'd
have just been normal and just come out
and said yeah I'm bisexual and you know
I like crystal meth every now and then
yeah everyone had been like cool let's
party and everything would have been
fine everything would have been fine I'm
not sure with that crowd he was trying
to play too well that's what I'm saying
like he should have played that I'm just
saying don't hang with that crowd yeah
yeah if that's the way you're like just
be what you're like and if and if you're
the crowd that you're in is not down
with that then find another crowd I'm
just saying don't have don't hang with
those people ball probably the way
they're thinking in those days well that
crowd that crowd doesn't have any money
the one that I would have to I'm gonna
try to go out the crowd that has the
money
but like I get it but I don't know nah
he could have I don't think I don't
think your mental health all these dudes
could have played it a lot better they
could have yeah
I just I just wish people would be more
yeah and I know that a lot of them were
raised like that and it's like maybe
they didn't really have much choice in
the matter but
I just went man yeah I just I'm so happy
every day that I wasn't raised religious
that had been like so sucky
because I'm just like I mean I would
have had I been I would have run far far
away but I'm just glad that I didn't
have to like put up with any of that
crap I was kind of raised religious have
to deal with anything but it was just
not real serious that's what I'm saying
yeah you weren't raised like [__]
hardcore no it wasn't a fundamentalist
no no I'm just saying like people like
that they were like super super strict
just yeah a lot of people were raised
like that like that's not even like
weird or anything I'm talking about
people that were like hardcore like
fundamentalists kind of like no doing
this and no doing that that's gotta suck
a lot all right so
man it's 11 o'clock and I really really
have to go to bed because I have to get
up very early in the morning yeah and
then we got a party tomorrow and we got
a party tomorrow thank you very much
people so I don't really get along I'm
not gonna get a lot of sleep but I'll
figure something out I'll get some
caffeine get some [__] going thank you
very much for dropping by and hanging
out with us this evening this was a very
fun show to do actually uh so yeah we'll
see you guys again on Friday night for
the Sidetrack show gonna be St Patrick's
Day so
I don't think we should go out on St
Patrick's Day because that shit's like
Amateur hour we'll go tonight after we
should probably go Saturday night but
when all the Bros are like sleeping it
off still is that I don't like going out
I'm like [__] drinking holidays
because everyone's like terrible but
yeah so we'll see you guys again on
Friday night for the Sidetrack show
hopefully you guys enjoy the show I
enjoyed doing it so we'll see you guys
again on Friday good night